Alter, Unity-Media
Was ist denn hier los?
Unity-Media, was ist hier los?
Was war das rumgelegge im Unity-Media?
Alter, Unity-Media
Was war da los?
Ich hab's genau gesehen
Ich hab's genau gesehen, Unity-Media
Es entgeht mir nichts, Unity-Media
Wenn ihr Kack-Performance habt
Ich seh alles
OKS
Ich seh übrigens noch kein Chat
Ich muss erstmal den zweiten Rechner anmachen
Aber
Warum steht da eigentlich nicht 60 FPS dahinter?
Habt ihr
Haben wir 60 FPS?
Nein, 60 FPS
Kambo, lässt man sich mal anzeichen
Jetzt
Wir haben 60 FPS
64 FPS
Ja
Big Brain FPS haben wir, sag ich euch, Leute
Huge Brain
Poggers Brain
Ja, weiß ich nicht so ganz
Als kann ich den Kamm mal zumachen
Weiß ich nicht so ganz
You can't install updates
We weren't able to install updates
Dacht Microsoft
Weiß ich nicht, egal
Hauptsache es funktioniert
Schon überstellt, ich bin da 2 Minuten an
Ah ja, so
Jetzt
Wunderbar
Muss
Muss ich erstmal vom letzten Streben den ganzen Kram hier zu machen
Was haben wir denn hier noch ruf?
Machen wir mal ein eigenes Fenster
Sonst mach ich aus dem Blick aus
Lautstärke müsste passen
Modes gehen auch
Schön
Bock
OK, nice
So, Unity-Media
Wird noch gelaggt?
Oder hat sich das erledigt?
Achso, welchen
Welchen Twitch-Server nehmen wir?
Achso, welchen Twitch-Server nehmen wir?
Ach, ich nehm immer noch Stockholm
Sollte ich vielleicht mal umstellen
Das hab ich letztens umgestellt, wo es so kaputt war
Warum stehen eigentlich die 60...
Der ist nicht...
Normalerweise stand da auch immer 60...
Dahinter
Oder?
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Oh, derjenige mit dem Namen, den ich nicht richtig aussprechen kann, ist 3 Monate dabei
GwOZ30Ogender
Big Brain Name, auf jeden Fall
Subscriber, nice!
Hehehe
Ehm...
Ja, aber, scheint alles zu funktionieren
Okay, sehr schön
6,6% CPU Last, das ist natürlich wie nix
Kiokon ist auch am Start
3 Monate aus mit langsam Zeit für die goldene Subscriber-Badge, die wir nicht am Start haben
Kümmer mich dieses Wochenende um Emotes und Subscriber-Badges
Ich muss nicht flamen über Unity.
Oh, mein Vorschau-Rechner hängt.
Vielleicht war das doch nicht gut, dass er keine Updates installiert.
Naja.
Guck mal, wenn man seinen eigenen Namen nicht mal schreiben kann.
Ist Mikrofon abgekackt?
Oh.
Ist es nicht.
Ist ganz schön leise heute.
Ich glaube, ich habe es zu weit weg.
So, ne?
Ups.
Warum labert das Video mit mir?
Was ist da los?
Das verwirrt mich.
So, wunderbar.
Alles gut.
Wie läuft es mit dem Fiverr-Projekt?
Es ist doch schon seit 2-3 Wochen fertig.
Musik ein bisschen leiser.
Ja, das machen wir.
30, 30.
Vielleicht ein bisschen zu leise.
Es ist geil, dass der Slider irgendwie rum ist.
Nicht richtig slidet.
Ja, so ist die Musik, denke ich.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich von der Lautstärke.
Gut.
So, also Leute.
Ähm, ich bin nicht so lange on.
2 Stunden oder so.
Mal gucken, er hat 2 Stunden, weil ich habe morgen den letzten Tag von meiner Microsoft-Azure-Schulung.
Und Leute, ich sage euch, es ist so krass langweilig.
Ich habe nichts gelernt, was ich nicht hätte alleine innerhalb von 45 Minuten lernen können.
Und es ist voll mit irgendwelchem Microsoft-Kack, wo kein Mensch draufkommt.
Irgendwelche komischen Assistenten, die du durchklicken musst.
Irgendwelche komischen Tools, die du dir auf 30 verschiedenen Seiten zusammensuchen musst.
Warum auch immer es da keinen Installer für Azure-Tools gibt oder sowas.
Man muss irgendwie so eine ganz merkwürdige, wenn man PowerShell verwenden will, muss man da irgendwie sich 20.000 Sachen nachinstallieren.
Es ist typisch Microsoft.
Aber das Schöne ist, das Schöne ist, es gibt eine, ein.
You're back.
Ein Azure-Command-Line-Tool.
Und das ist richtig nice.
Das heißt, dass Azure, Microsoft Azure, scheint wirklich das erste Produkt von Microsoft zu sein, was sich unter Linux besser bedienen lässt als unter Windows.
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, was mit Microsoft da los ist.
Aber ich bin der Letzte, der damit irgendwelche Probleme hat.
Wenn DB so scheiße ist, wieso nicht FlixTrain nutzen?
Ne, weil FlixTrain meine Strecke nicht fährt.
Das ist einfach.
Kannst du einen Vergleich zu AWS ziehen?
Ne, ich habe beides noch nicht genug verwendet.
Im Vergleich zu AWS, also AWS habe ich eigentlich gar nicht verwendet.
Also ich sage mal, so gut wie gar nicht.
Zu Google kann ich auch nichts sagen.
Pornetes, das ist ja eher was zum Selbsthosten.
Gibt es da auch Manage-Plattformen.
Aber Azure ist, glaube ich, wenn man sich das so anguckt, auf jeden Fall die letzten Jahre zu einem der wichtigsten Cloud-Anbieter aufgestiegen.
Und eine Sache habe ich schon gecheckt.
An dieser ganzen Microsoft-Azure-Geschichte.
Jeder noch so kleinste Furz, den du lässt, kostet.
Also es kostet in Azure wirklich gefühlt alles irgendwas.
Kannst in Azure gar nicht mal irgendwie auf die Idee kommen, mal was anzuklicken.
Das kostet gleich Instant.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht ohne.
Ansonsten habe ich halt in diesem komischen Azure-Training von Microsoft.
Wer das interessiert, das ist das Azure-Training, das Operation-Azure-Training oder so wie ich es heiße.
Azure-Training 103 ist das.
Der Microsoft-Azure-Administrator-Training, Fastlane-Training.
Das ist also quasi für die Leute mit besonders großem Brain, die einfach nur ganz kurze Erklärungen brauchen, alles Instant checken.
Also quasi wie gemacht für Next-Level-Big-Brain-Leute wie mich.
Und ich glaube, dass der Kurs an sich gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Aber unser Typ, der das hält, man kann sich ja mal so ein Beispiel davon angucken.
Die machen übrigens ein mega Secret um ihre Schulungsunterlagen.
Ich habe mir schon gedacht, ob wir uns nicht einfach mal ganz kurz die Schulungsunterlagen von Azure hier im Stream angucken.
Aber die sind richtig, die sind übelst hinterher.
Du darfst die, die haben, die geben.
Die geben dir Schulungsunterlagen, aber das ist so typische Microsoft-Stells-Geschichte.
Die geben dir Schulungsunterlagen für diesen Kurs.
Die kannst du allerdings nur online angucken, nur seitenweise.
Und wenn du speicherst, kommt nur Mist bei raus.
Also die haben da wirklich DRM-Schulungsunterlagen.
Und alles, also es ist echt mega für den Arsch.
Zumindest das größte Problem an diesem Kurs.
Muss ich jetzt einfach mal so sagen, ist der Typ, der den Kurs macht, bei uns.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer es ist, ich will ihn jetzt auch nicht blamen.
Ich würde eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass er schon ordentlich Übung haben müsste in diesem Kurs.
Aber irgendwie, es wirkt auf mich übelst unstrukturiert.
Und auch mega langweilig gemacht.
Eigentlich hat dieser Fastlane, dieses Fastlane-Training für Azure, hat eigentlich ziemlich viele Übungen drin.
Und wir machen keine Übung.
Der Typ geht die ganze Zeit.
Der Typ geht die ganze Zeit nur Powerpoint-Präsentationen durch.
Heute haben wir mal eine Übung gemacht.
Und die Übung bestand Microsoft-typisch aus.
Klicke hier drauf.
Dann geht so ein Azure-Lab auf, wo du ausprobieren kannst.
Und dann, nicht etwa, dass da in der Übung drinsteht, so nach dem Motto,
erstellen Sie drei VMs und einen Loadbalancer und probieren Sie aus, dass alles funktioniert.
Nein.
Die Übung, die Übung, oder sagen wir mal, der, der...
Der Test, ja.
Der sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Du klickst auf den Öffnen-Knopf und dann hast du neben einer Anleitung, wo drin steht, ganz genau, was du machen musst.
Also es ist nicht, dass du was lernst.
In dem Training, also in diesem Trainings-Lab, oder wo man übt, steht dann so nach dem Motto drin,
klicken Sie jetzt auf alle Ressourcen.
Klicken Sie auf Computing.
Klicken Sie auf virtuelle Maschine anlegen.
Klicken Sie auf Microsoft Data Center.
Äh, Windows.
Windows Data Center 2016 Edition.
Klicken Sie auf Weiter.
Klicken Sie auf Network.
Klicken Sie jetzt hier auf Public IP erstellen.
Fragen Sie die Public IT IP ein.
Klicken Sie jetzt hier auf Weiter.
Das ist, das ist doch kein, keine Übung.
Was soll das denn sein?
Ja, und geben Sie Ihre Kreditkarteninfos ein.
Aber wir haben zum Glück 100, 100 Dollar Credit, wo wir rumsauen können.
Und ich habe heute ganze, passt mal auf, wie viel Geld ich heute in meiner Azure-Schulung ausgegeben habe.
Ganze 2,10 Euro.
Also ohne Scheiß, was ich bisher in dieser Azure-Schulung gemacht habe,
hätte ich in 45 Minuten alleine rausgekriegt.
Es ist auch, es ist ja auch vor allem nicht kompliziert gemacht.
Die haben das, ich muss sagen, man, du kannst wirklich in Azure, also in dieser Microsoft Cloud,
kannst du wirklich allen möglichen Scheiß einstellen.
Alles, und alles kostet auch irgendwie extra.
Aber sie haben es geschafft, dass es irgendwie noch ansatzweise selbsterklärend ist, wie du was machst.
Du brauchst, musst dir so ein paar Basics merken, dass du nicht VMs anlegst,
sondern erstmal Netzwerkkarten anlegst, IPs anlegst.
Und dann VMs anlegst und das verbindest und sowas, ist ja alles okay.
Aber wenn man das mal gecheckt hat, geht das auch.
Aber langweilig, da kann man echt so einen Kurs nicht, nicht aufbauen.
So war die SAP-Schulung bei uns an der Uni, ja.
Viele Schulen, so Schulungen sind leider so langweilig.
Ich dachte, der Tiefpunkt war diese eine Cisco-Schulung, die ich mal vor Jahren gemacht habe.
Die war nämlich ähnlich, aber die war im Endeffekt noch interessanter,
weil du ab und zu mal ein paar Kabel in den Switch stöpseln durftest.
Aber ansonsten war alles, ist das wirklich...
Übelst, übelst langweilig.
Wie kann man sich so eine Schulung als unwissender vorstellen?
Ähnlich wie Schule.
Diese Schulung, schlimmer als Schule.
In der Schule hast du noch...
Also, so wie der das macht.
Ich gehe nämlich mal davon aus, wenn das jemand macht, der das gut kann,
dann ist das auch deutlich interessanter, weil Azure ist eigentlich ein interessantes Thema.
Also die normale Schulung ist eigentlich ein bisschen, ein bisschen wie Schule.
Du hast irgendeinen Typ, der kennt sich halt damit aus, der steht dann vorne, erklärt dir ein bisschen was.
Und je nachdem, was das für ein Typ ist, der kennt sich halt damit aus, der steht dann vorne, erklärt dir ein bisschen was.
Und je nachdem, was das für ein Typ von Schulung ist, ist es halt mehr, so mehr mit Practice oder halt mehr mit Theorie und Geschwätze.
Hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, wie das macht, wer das macht und was man auch für eine Schulung gebucht hat.
Aber man kann sich das schon ein bisschen wie Schulung vorstellen, so eine Schulung.
Allerdings, bei dem ist das schlimmer als Schule, weil Schule ist noch ein bisschen interaktiv, ja.
Da fragt der Lehrer ab und zu mal was, ja.
Und wenn es dich interessiert, kannst du was sagen oder kannst sagen, es ist mir wurscht.
Aber das geht ja...
Ich meine, du kannst da schon was fragen, aber es gibt nichts zu fragen.
Aber das geht ja... Ich meine, du kannst da schon was fragen, aber es gibt nichts zu fragen.
Weil das einfach nur Powerpoint-Präsentationen durchgeklickt ist bei dem.
Das ist wirklich übelst langweilig.
Außerdem spricht er die meisten englischen Wörter noch, noch merkwürdiger aus als ich.
Der sagt zum Beispiel, ähm...
Storage, Storage Tier, ja.
Also...
So, so wie, so wie das deutsche Tier, also so das, das, das, also...
So, so wie man Tier ausspricht, so.
Also Animal auf Englisch, so Storage Tier, also die Stufe vom...
Vom, vom Storage, also sprich, ist das eine SSD, ist das, ist das Platten, also wie, wie schnell ist der Zugriff da drauf?
Storage Tier spricht ja die ganze Zeit Storage Tire aus.
Da krieg ich übelste Anfälle.
Ich denk die ganze Zeit an irgendein Rad, was da durch mein Rechenzentrum fährt, wenn da einer mit Storage Tire ankommt.
Das heißt Storage Tier, das ist wie, wie wenn du, keine Ahnung, Tier 1, äh, Epic-Rüstung hast oder sowas.
Ach ja, und, und, und Q...
Ups.
Ach ja, und Q...
Also das da, Warteschlange, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das auf Deutsch, ob man das auf Deutsch Warteschlange nennt, ähm...
Wie heißt denn das eigentlich auf Deutsch?
Warteschlange, tatsächlich, weiter, Warteschlange heißt, ja.
Spricht der, äh, siehst du hier, hier steht sogar die Aussprache, Q spricht man das aus.
Q!
Und der Kerl sagt dazu Q-E.
Da dachte, da denk ich immer an den, an, an, an den Heli aus Modern Warfare 2.
So, erst, erst, erst mal Payflow am Start, äh.
So.
Aber es, aber es wird alles, es wird alles noch getoppt.
Es wird echt alles noch getoppt.
Gateway.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man dazu überhaupt, äh, eine Aussprache hier dahinter hat.
Ich dachte die ganze Zeit Gutway dazu.
Das, das triggert mich jedes Mal, wenn er sagt, der Gutway.
Wir müssen ein Gutway-Netz anlegen, oder, oder Get, Getway.
Getway-Netz, Gutway, Gutway sagt er, Gutway-Netz.
Das triggert mich immer übel.
Da, da muss ich mich immer zusammenreißen.
Frag ihn mal, wie er GIF oder GIF ausspricht, das müsste ich echt machen.
Also ich kann diesen Kurs echt nicht empfehlen.
Falls den irgendjemand auf der Arbeit vorgeschlagen kriegt, oder gefragt kriegt, ob er den machen, machen möchte.
Kann ich echt nicht empfehlen.
Es könnte sein, dass dieser, dieser, dieser Azure Fast Training Kurs ganz gut ist.
Aber es scheint mir sehr, viel zu sehr abhängig davon, wer den macht.
Und das bei uns ist einfach stinke langweilig, und man lernt nix.
Wie viel seid ihr in der Schulung?
Ist das so ein 100-Leute-Online-Ding?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, die haben da richtig Geld für bezahlt.
Das ist Offline, Offline-Training bei uns in der Firma, von einem, von einem Typ, der es eigentlich kann.
Das sind, das sind, wir sind sechs Leute.
Also eigentlich was, wo man was lernen könnte.
Aber macht man ja nicht.
Weil.
Ja, und es ist auch noch bei uns in der Firma, also.
No Happy Meal, drei Monate.
Samus Climber, Samus Climber.
He, he, Face-Gesicht.
Muss ich ja gleich Face rollen.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Muss jetzt mal schnell gucken, dass ich nichts übersehen hab.
Streamlabs.
Ähm, zumindest, ey, es ist, es ist der Wahnsinn.
Da hab ich mir erst mal genug drüber ausgekotzt, aber es war wirklich ätzend.
Läuft's jetzt eigentlich ordentlich hier, der Stream, oder leckt's rum?
Weil am Anfang hat's, am Anfang hat's ja ein bisschen bugged.
EVE1337, Twitch Prime Sub, Poggers, Samus Climber, nice, Geocron hatten wir schon, ne?
Der, aber trotzdem, aber danke für den Sub, SilentPain, Resubbed, drei Monate.
Samus Climber.
Irgendwie, jetzt gehen die Subs aber ab.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie viele Subs ich überhaupt hab jetzt.
Wir haben nämlich schon wieder ein neues Sub-Goal erreicht.
So langsam, aber sicher muss ich echt mal beikommen.
Mit meinen Emotes.
Wie viel haben wir denn jetzt?
366.
Heide Global Elite, Twitch Prime.
Jetzt geht's aber echt ab.
Samus Climber.
Warum steht Any% in den Stream-Texts?
Da ist ja irgendwo Any%.
Nice.
Wir fangen immer Sachen an und machen sie nie fertig.
Also es ist quasi, mehr oder weniger, die Definition von Any%.
Ähm, also machen sie nie komplett fertig, so rum.
Ja.
Bei Any% geht's ja, dass du es irgendwie fertig machst.
Das machen wir ja meistens.
Hawks.
Twitch Prime.
Zwei Monate.
Ja, aber jetzt habe ich mich genug über diese komische Azure-Sache ausgekotzt.
Ich meine, im Endeffekt ist der Morgen wieder vorbei, ne?
Jetzt ist letzter Tag.
Mal gucken, was wir am letzten Tag machen.
Vielleicht machen wir noch ein paar Übungen, aber es ist...
Was hältst du von Code Wars?
Weiß jetzt, sagt mir jetzt gar nichts.
Ist das diese Geschichte, wo du...
Ist das quasi das, wo es auch diese...
Diese, wer schreibt...
Wer schreibt...
Ist das diese, wer schreibt schneller Geschichte?
Ich muss euch übrigens auch fragen, Leute.
Was ich für ein nächstes Video machen soll.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher.
Und zwar...
Ich habe zur Auswahl...
Einmal wollte ich ja noch ein Fazit machen zur Modern Warfare Beta.
Alternativ habe ich mir gedacht, ich verbinde das mal ein bisschen damit.
Ne, ich habe zwei Sachen...
Oder drei Sachen zur Auswahl.
Entweder ein Code-Fazit...
Modern Warfare Beta-Fazit-Video.
Oder aber in Kombination mit, dass ich mich darüber aufrege, dass wahrscheinlich...
Ein nicht unerheblicher Teil von Modern Warfare 4...
Zumindest Gerüchte nach.
Ich glaube offiziell bestätigt ist das immer noch nicht.
Muss ich mal nachgucken.
PS4 exklusiv sein wird.
Dieser komische Spec Ops Survival Mode.
Gehen da die Gerüchte um, dass der...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das mittlerweile bestätigt ist.
Vielleicht weiß das einer von euch.
Dass das PS4 exklusiv sein soll.
Das ist eine Sache, die kann ich nicht unterstützen.
Und...
Ich bin eh kein Freund von Exklusivität.
Wenn...
Also...
Gegen ein bisschen exklusive Inhalte habe ich nichts.
Aber...
Wenn ein kompletter Spielmodus exklusiv ist.
Auf einer anderen Plattform.
Und nicht etwa irgendwie für 1-2 Wochen.
Sondern für ein ganzes Jahr.
Ist das absolut der Rotz.
Gut, ich bin nur kurz zum Subben da.
Huge Sub.
Kommt kein Battle Royale.
Weiß ich nicht.
So.
Und...
Das nächste, was ich...
Also das ist eine Videosache, die man machen könnte.
Ähm...
Das zweite ist eine Sache, wo ich mich...
Auch echt drüber aufgeregt habe gestern.
Ich habe auf Reddit...
Auf...
Ähm...
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe...
Ich habe sau viel Overwatch gespielt zur Release.
Und das meist gelesene Subreddit, was ich damals gelesen habe, war...
Competitive Overwatch.
Das waren auch die Zeiten, wo wir Skrims gesucht haben mit dem Team.
Und übelst, übelst...
Reingesuchtet haben.
Ja, und...
Auch relativ gut waren für die damalige Zeit.
So.
Und...
Ganz viele bei Overwatch...
Hier im Overwatch...
Sub...
Competitive Overwatch Subreddit.
Ja...
Oh Gott.
Ja, neues Reddit-Design.
Geh mal fort.
Ähm...
Ja, so ist das doch schon klar.
Wie kommt man eigentlich auf die Idee...
Sowas Schönes hier...
Mit...
Mit ner ordentlicher Navigation und so...
Sowas Merkwürdigem umzubauen.
Ich bin jetzt, weil ich gelesen habe...
Ähm...
Hat jetzt...
Es hat nur begrenzt, was mit Overwatch zu...
Also es hat...
Nein.
Es hat...
Es hat schon viel mit Overwatch zu tun.
Aber das Problem ist nicht Overwatch.
Und zwar...
Ich weiß nicht, wer sich...
Wer sich...
Wer interessiert sich für euch...
Für den Overwatch World Cup?
Und hat sich da...
Hat...
Hat da schon ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Gibt's da den ein oder anderen...
Ich mein...
Ich guck wenig...
In letzter Zeit wenig Competitive Overwatch.
Ich guck...
Ab und zu mal Overwatch-Lequence läuft.
Ähm...
Aber...
Ich muss sagen...
Die World Cup Games hab ich jetzt nie großartig verfolgt.
Aber...
Ähm...
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Aushängeschild von Overwatch World...
Das Niveau mag im World Cup, mag in der OVL natürlich höher sein und das Niveau ist auch zum größten Teil in Contenders höher.
Aber der World Cup ist einfach das, wo viele Leute gucken.
So, und wisst ihr, was Blizzard jetzt macht?
Wo ich nicht verstehe, warum sich irgendwie keiner drüber beschwert.
Die haben ihre Regeln geändert.
Ich zeige euch das mal.
Die haben ihre Regeln geändert für den Overwatch World Cup.
Und zwar, ja, das haben die vor 5 Monaten schon geschrieben.
So, und zwar steht da so Sachen drin, wie das zum Beispiel nur die Top 10, wo steht es denn?
Da denkt man sich erstmal noch gar nichts dabei, wenn man das so sieht.
So, also der erste Witz ist schon mal das Format.
Die...
Die machen das jetzt so, dass es quasi keine nationalen Ausscheidungsdinger, Qualifier mehr gibt.
Sondern, dass es quasi auf der BlizzCon, bevor die BlizzCon offiziell losgeht, gibt es quasi Vorrunde, wenn man es so will.
So, das Problem an der Vorrunde ist, kann ich jetzt gleich schon mal sagen, es ist Open Single Elimination Bracket.
Single Elimination Bracket ist so ziemlich das Beknackte.
Das ist das wichtigste Turnierformat, was es gibt.
Single Elimination bedeutet, du verlierst ein Spiel und bist raus.
Double Elimination ist viel schöner.
Double Elimination ist eigentlich das, was man von den meisten Turnieren kennt.
Wenn die das nicht in der Liga machen oder in der Gruppenphase machen.
Double Elimination ist diese Geschichte mit, man verliert, kommt ins Lower Bracket, man verliert nochmal und man ist raus.
So.
Oder aber, man verliert einmal und gewinnt danach alle Spiele.
Dann kommt man auch weiter.
So.
Ähm, so.
Single Elimination ist schon mal übelst fail.
Aber, das ist ja nur, das ist, das ist noch gar nicht so wild.
Der, der Witz kommt jetzt, kommt jetzt ja gleich.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie sie das hier hingeschrieben hat.
How to get involved.
So, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Wo steht das denn mit dem Hotel?
Haben sie das jetzt rausge...
Ach, hier.
National Rankings.
Also, die, die, die, die 10 Teams, die besten 10 Teams vom letzten Jahr.
Hier.
Ähm.
Before match start.
Bla bla bla bla.
Das Point.
Ähm.
Wo steht's denn?
Genau.
Also, das Ganze wird gesiedelt, je nachdem, wie das, wie das ist.
Wo steht's denn jetzt genau?
Hier.
Competition.
Place.
10 highest ranked Teams.
So, das sind also die, die im Prinzip im letzten Jahr gewonnen haben.
Die bekommen vollen Support.
Das heißt, die bekommen ihren Trip, also die bekommen die Reisekosten erstattet.
Die, die bekommen Anreise erstattet.
Die kriegen, äh, das Hotel bezahlt und alles ist gut.
So, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Jetzt kommt der absolute Knaller, Leute.
Der absolute Knaller.
Alle anderen Länder, die teilnehmen wollen, sind komplett selbst dafür verantwortlich,
ähm, ihre Reisekosten und, und Unterhalt und alles zu bezahlen.
Da frage ich mich nur, Alter, was, was, was, was, was, was geht mit Blizzard eigentlich ab?
Ich meine, wie soll, wie soll ein Team, wie soll ein Team, ach ja, und, äh, okay, Moment, ich, ich muss ja das mal, das, das der Reihe nach machen.
Wie soll ein Team, das sagen wir mal aus, ups, äh, Moment, ich, fuck, was mit meinem, ich hab mich gemutet irgendwie, warte mal kurz, äh, fuck, Alter, okay.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's.
Okay, ähm, wie soll ein Team aus, sagen wir mal, was weiß ich.
Gibt's ein, äh, Trinidad and Tobago oder so, falls dieses Land so heißt, oder, sagen wir mal, sagt, nehmen wir mal einfach Team Südafrika, ja.
Südafrika ist jetzt nicht so ein ganz dritter Weltland, aber Südafrika hat jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Kohle.
Ähm, wie soll ein Team wie Südafrika, wie sollen die sich das leisten?
Wie sollen die sich das leisten?
So, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was die ganzen Teams jetzt machen?
Übrigens Team Germany auch, Team Germany auch, ähm, die machen jetzt alle, äh, Crowdfounding.
Die machen jetzt alle GoFoundMe und machen, machen quasi, ähm, äh, äh, Streams, wo die Leute spenden können und sowas.
Und das ist, wenn man sich das mal auf der Zunge, auf, auf der, wie gesagt, in CS-Kick kein Team was bezahlt, das ist was komplett anderes.
Das hier sind No-Name-Teams, das sind No-Name-Teams ohne Sponsor, die noch nicht mal ihren Sponsor, selbst wenn die Teams, selbst wenn die Teams einen Sponsor hätten,
die dürfen es nicht auf das Trikot machen.
Das sind, das sind kein, das sind No-Name-Teams.
Das sind zum größten, zum größten Teil No-Name-Player.
Da ist keine Orga und nix dahinter.
Und, und selbst eine Orga würde sich das zweimal überlegen, da was zu supporten, weil die Spieler noch nicht mal den Kram auf dem fucking Trikot tragen dürfen.
Die meisten Spieler, die, die, die im World Cup mitmachen aus den 50 Ländern sind im Vergleich zur Overwatch League No-Names.
Da sponsert keiner einfach mal nebenbei 15k.
Da geht's aber auch überhaupt nicht drum.
Es geht da drum, dass das ist.
Also wo ich jetzt zurückkomme, dass ich das eigentlich eine Sauerei von Blizzard finde.
Es ist die offizielle Messe von Blizzard.
Es ist das offizielle Overwatch World Cup Turnier.
Es ist quasi der offizielle Stream.
Die gehen dahin, die spielen für Blizzard ein Spiel von Blizzard auf dem offiziellen Stream, das dem Spiel Hype gibt und, und sonst was.
Und dass Blizzard überhaupt diese Veranstaltung machen kann, ist nur diesen Spielern zu verdanken.
Und Blizzard sagt einfach, oh nö.
Da bezahlen wir nix für.
Und der Hit ist, es gibt Overwatch World Cup Trikots.
Das passt man auf.
Die sehen übrigens übelst wie Arsch aus.
Es hat irgendwie einer ne coole Seite gemacht mit der, mit der, mit der Übersicht.
Es hat irgendwie einer ne coole Übersichtsseite gemacht.
Overview.
Ähm, die meine ich nicht.
Übrigens, erstens sehen die Dinger voll für n Arsch aus.
Die Overwatch World Cup Hose.
Also, das sind die uninspiriert.
Das sind die uninspiriert.
Das sind die uninspiriertsten World Cup T-Shirts, die ich je gesehen hab.
Und der Witz ist, es gibt offizielle World Cup T-Shirts.
Und was meint ihr, wie viel die Teams von den Verkäufen der Overwatch T-Shirts, der World Cup T-Shirts abbekommen?
Laut meinen letzten Informationen, die ich gelesen hab, nix.
Nix.
Das ist gar Maß.
Ohne Ende, Alter.
Was ist mit, was ist mit Blizzard los?
Was ist mit Blizzard los?
Das kann man nicht mit nem CSGO-Turnier vergleichen.
Ich würd mir ja irgendwie wünschen, dass alle Teams sagen, Blizzard, leck mich.
Und wir fahren einfach nicht hin.
Da sollen sie einfach Korea den Auto-Win geben.
Sollen einfach Korea den Auto-Win geben und sagen, gut ist.
So.
Und es ist ja nicht mal so, als würde das, ähm, es ist ja noch nicht mal so, als würde das Blizzard wahnsinnig viel Geld kosten.
Guck mal.
50.000 Euro für nen Team.
Für 50 Teams.
Das sind 750.000 Euro.
Was zum Teufel interessiert Blizzard 750.000 Euro?
Ich hab auf Reddit Leute gesehen, die diese Scheiße verteidigen.
Die sagen dann, ja, aber Blizzard muss auch gucken, dass sie irgendwie mit Geld verdienen.
Die verdienen genug Geld.
Die sollen sich den letzten Financial Report mal angucken.
Die verdienen Milliarden.
Als wäre 750.000 Euro, das ist für Blizzard ungefähr, das ist für Blizzard, ist das weniger,
als ihr dem Dönermann.
Als Trinkgeld gibt.
Ja.
Und, und selbst wenn du als Team gut spielst und in die Preisgeld-Ränge kommst, da hast du grad mal deine Ausgaben rein.
Dass die Leute, ich versteh gar nicht, warum da überhaupt jemand freiwillig hinfährt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaub das Preisgeld ist noch nicht, ist noch nicht announced.
Ja, Small Indie Company, denk, 750.000 Euro, das ist nix.
750.000 Euro, das, das, das ist das, was, wie, wie, wie heißt der Typ nochmal?
Bobby Kotick oder so, wie man damit ausspricht.
Was dem Activision-Chef.
Der Typ, der sich so aus Versehen aus der Tasche fällt, wenn er in der Kantine was bezahlen will.
750.000 Euro.
Das ist nix!
Und, außerdem, ja, Freddy hat Recht, natürlich, das ist, das ist pures Marketing.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die den World, dass die am World Cup viel verdienen würden.
Aber gerade deswegen, weil es pures Marketing ist, warum bezahlt man eigentlich für die Leute, die quasi die Aushängeschilder dieses Marketings sind, nämlich Spieler.
Warum gibt man den ...
Warum gibt man den....
Mann, es ist ja nicht so, dass die umsonst spielen würden.
Also normalerweise müsste man sagen, okay, man kriegt die Anreise bezahlt,
man kriegt den Aufenthalt bezahlt, man kriegt Verpflegung bezahlt
und man kriegt noch eine Aufwandspauschale fürs Spielen.
So müsstest du das eigentlich machen.
Aber Blizzard, es sagt ja nicht nur, du kriegst kein Geld fürs Spielen,
quasi die Spieler, die dafür sorgen,
dass die überhaupt dieses marketingträchtige Turnier abhalten können,
kriegen kein Geld.
Nein, die scheißen nochmal doppelt drauf und sagen,
nicht nur ihr kriegt kein Geld, keine Aufwandsentschädigung, sonst was.
Nein, ihr müsst die komplette Scheiße auch noch selbst bezahlen.
Und jetzt kommt der Super, jetzt kommt noch der absolute Topper.
Jetzt toppen wir das Ganze nochmal.
Wenn ihr jetzt schon denkt, Blizzard hat sie eh schon wieder mal,
dann muss ich euch mal diesen Clip zeigen von einem Spieler aus dem offiziellen Overwatch-Team.
Das müsst ihr euch jetzt mal ganz genau anhören, was der sagt.
Und dann zweifelt ihr wirklich da dran, was mit Blizzard los ist.
Was ist mir denn geschickt?
Das hat mir doch jemand auf Reddit, das hat mir doch jemand auf, hier, hört euch das mal an.
Das ist, äh, das ist aus dem Stream von Raidy, das ist ein Spieler, glaubt, Mei, Mei-Spieler aus dem deutschen Overwatch-Team.
Jetzt hört euch das mal genau an, was der sagt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welcher Clip das ist, deswegen gucken wir uns mal, gucken wir uns mal beides an.
Was ist denn los? Ich töte drei von ihnen.
Gibt es wenigstens das Preisgeld? Ja, wenn du weiterkommst.
Aber ich meine, du bekommst auch nur Essen, du bekommst auch nur Essen von Blizzard, solange du im Turnier bist.
Sobald du aus dem Turnier rausgehst, ist Blizzard nicht mehr da.
Du bekommst nicht mehr Essen, du bekommst nicht mehr Essen für kostenlos.
Ihr kratzt das irgendwie zusammen.
Ihr macht Crowdfounding, ihr macht alles, was geht, ja.
Ihr sponsort das im Prinzip noch quasi mit, ihr sponsort quasi Blizzard, weil die kein Geld haben, das auszurichten anscheinend.
Ihr Crowdfoundet es.
Wenn sowas gecrowdfoundet wird, das bedeutet, dass im Prinzip die größten Fans dieses Spiels, das sind diejenigen, die crowdfunden,
ähm, das ist übelst grotesk.
Diejenigen, die ein Overwatch-Team crowdfunden, das sind mit die größten Fans von Overwatch.
Sonst würden sie das nicht crowdfounden.
Sprich, das sind die Leute, die eh schon mehr als genug Geld Blizzard gegeben haben, ähm, was meinst du, ein MainSound?
Ein MainSound ist doch, meinst du ein Mikro?
Nee, du meinst, du meinst Desktop, ne?
Ähm, zumindest das sind die Leute, die eh schon sau viel Geld an Blizzard gegeben haben.
Die sollen quasi Blizzard jetzt noch sponsoren, dass sie das ausrichten können.
Das ist, das ist übelst, übelst grotesk.
So, und jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr seid ein Team aus einem Land, wo 15.000 Euro übelst viel Geld sind.
Und ihr kratzt das zusammen, crowdfunding von den Leuten, die eh schon genug Geld an Blizzard bezahlt haben.
Ihr, ihr nehmt euer Erspartes vielleicht noch.
Ihr fahrt auf die BlizzCon.
Ihr habt vielleicht noch irgendwelche, irgendwelche Einreise-Sonstwas-Probleme, ja?
Also ihr seid wahrscheinlich eh schon, ihr müsst euch um den ganzen Scheiß kümmern.
Das ist die Zeit, wo ihr nicht trainieren könnt, nicht üben könnt, nicht scrimmen könnt, nicht sonst was machen.
Ich weiß, dafür gibt's eigentlich den, den Team-Typ, aber da müssen sich alle drum kümmern.
So, und dann kommt ihr da an.
Und vielleicht habt ihr Pech.
Ja, und landet, landet im ersten Match, äh, gegen einen Gegner, der, der euch entweder haushoch überlegen ist,
oder ihr verliert das erste Match unglücklich.
So, Single Elimination.
Ihr seid direkt raus.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal, in welchem Format das hier gespielt wird.
Ist es Best of Three?
Wahrscheinlich ist es, wahrscheinlich ist es BO3.
Wahrscheinlich ist es BO3, denke ich mal.
BO1 wäre ja, na gut, ich trau Blizzard alles zu.
Ähm, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es BO3 oder BO5, wahrscheinlich BO3.
So.
Ihr geht dann dahin, ihr habt quasi euer, sogar noch euer Erspartes dafür ausgegeben.
Ihr verliert unglücklich, ihr seid direkt raus.
Und dann sagt Blizzard nach dem Essen, meh, jetzt kriegst du doch nicht mehr was zu fressen.
Das ist sowas von dem, also das, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Ich weiß wirklich, ich weiß echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Und was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum das, es sind acht Leute, ja, hast recht.
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum erstens das Leute auf Reddit überhaupt, überhaupt verteidigen.
Und warum?
Weil keiner sich irgendwie über dieses, über, über diese Sache aufregt.
Da mach ich auch ein Video drüber.
Ich warte jetzt noch, ich hab, ich hab an Blizzard was geschrieben.
Ich wollte mal denen ihre Meinung, ich werd natürlich nicht drauf antworten.
Da kannst du, kannst du voll ausgeht, dass Blizzard nicht da drauf antworten wird.
Ähm, ich wollte noch warten, bis die, bis der deutsche Teammanager, äh, Teammanagerin antworten kann.
Noch was, falls du noch was antworten willst.
Ähm, und dann mach ich da mal ein Video zu.
Weil wenn das wirklich alles so ist, vielleicht hab, vielleicht hab ich auch irgendeinen Punkt,
Leute verteidigen das, ja, die sagen, ach ja, Blizzard verdient mit dem Overwatch World Cup ja kein Geld.
Da müssen die ja gucken, dass das irgendwie plus minus null geht.
Äh, ich, ich glaube, Nozerino ist der Community Manager und, und, äh, Zuki ist, äh, ne, umgedreht.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ist, ist, im Prinzip geht ja auch im Blizzard.
Ähm, also, ich gönn das den Leuten aus Deutschland wirklich, dass die da hinfahren.
Ich wollte schon kurz, kurz sagen, als ich gesehen hab, dass die auch Probleme haben, die Kohle zusammen zu kriegen.
Ich wollte schon ganz kurz auf Twitter schreiben, Leute, ich bezahl euch den Kram.
Aber erstens, es ist ein Game, was mich persönlich nicht mal so großartig interessiert.
Und zweitens will ich Blizzard keine 7.000 Euro geben.
Das will ich einfach nicht.
Das seh ich nicht ein.
Da irgendwie was, was zu bezahlen.
Das soll gefälligst Blizzard machen, das ist denen ihr scheiß Turnier.
Und als wären 750.000 Euro für, Euro für Blizzard wirklich viel Geld.
Ich wünsche wirklich den Leuten, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da, die da.
Die Teams, also ich wünsche Blizzard erstmal einen scheiß World Cup für diese Aktion.
Aber ich wünsche den Teams selber, dass sie es hinkriegen mit ihrem Crowdfounding.
Dass die ein super Event haben, ja, dass die schöne Erinnerungen haben.
Ich mein, das ist ja auch, das ist so eine Sache, das machst du einmal im Leben.
Wenn du jetzt, wenn du nicht grad wirklich Pro wirst.
Höchstens zweimal, ja.
Ich glaub die höchste Teilnahme irgendwie wird wahrscheinlich zweimal sein, außer bei manchen Pros beim World Cup.
Das machst du einmal im Leben.
Da hinfahren und an diesem Event als Spieler teilnehmen.
Deswegen, ich gönn das den Leuten wirklich.
Und ich, ich, ich freu mich für die Leute, wenn das klappt.
Die sind teilweise auch noch relativ jung, da hast du Leute dabei, die sind in Kammer 18, 18, 19.
Ähm, für, für die ist das, für die ist das natürlich super.
Deswegen, für die hoffe ich wirklich, dass das klappt.
Aber, so wie das Blizzard hier macht, das kann ich nicht gut heißen, ähm.
Und ich mein, die werden doch garantiert, garantiert bringen die wieder irgendwelche World Cups.
Ja.
World Cup Skins raus, hundertprozentig.
Genau, Freddy.
Die bringen hundertprozentig irgendwelche World Cup Skins wieder raus.
Mit dem ganzen Krempel, mit den Trikots, mit den World Cup Skins, da wäre wahrscheinlich schon mal ein Großteil der Kosten für die Verpflegung und Anreise der Teams wieder drinne.
Und selbst wenn nicht, wir haben uns letztens mal den letzten Financial Report angeguckt.
750k.
Ja, natürlich kostet das gesamte Event und die Organisation dieses Cups natürlich bedeutend mehr, wie das, was man bezahlen muss für die Spieler, ja.
Keine Frage, aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass die Spieler die Leidtragenden sind.
Eigentlich sollten, wenn wirklich, als Spieler solltest du eigentlich bei so einem Event, ich nenn's mal so ein bisschen in Watte gepackt sein, dass du dich auf nichts anderes konzentrieren musst, außer gut zu spielen.
Du solltest dir als Spieler nicht Gedanken machen müssen, ob du abends noch was essst.
Oder was du essen kannst.
Naja.
Ist Blizzard eine AG?
Aber sowas von.
Die Activision Blizzard Aktie, der geht übrigens wieder besser.
Ich hoffe, ihr freut euch alle, ja.
War das Umsatz oder Gewinn?
Naja, erstes Mal ist Umsatz ja generell alle Einnahmen.
Minus das, was du ausgegeben hast, ist, wenn du Glück hast, Gewinn.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, was genau im Financial Report.
Drinnen stand, aber die bringen jedes Quartal einen Financial Report raus.
Du kannst dir angucken, wenn du es genau wissen willst.
Und wenn man, selbst wenn man als, als, sag man mal, als Außenseiter-Team weiterkommt.
Du musst, ich hab keine Ahnung, wann es wie viel Preisgeld gibt, ja.
Du musst schon ganz schön weit kommen, dass du überhaupt deine Aufwände reinbekommst.
Und das, das kann nicht sein.
Das kann echt nicht sein.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was diese BlizzCon noch drankommt.
Ob wir was Neues hören zu Diablo Mobile.
Was, was, was gibt's da, gibt's da eigentlich was Schönes zu, was Neues irgendwie?
Da hat man jetzt ein Jahr lang nix gehört.
Ja, neue WoW-Expansion ist wahrscheinlich so sicher.
Oh.
Kein Release dieses Jahr, natürlich.
Ganz furchtbar traurig.
Ich, ich mach mir jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Gedanken drüber, äh, was ich, was ich, ähm.
Wie ich das genau verpacke, ja.
Weil ich will jetzt kein Video machen, wo ich das hier so wie im Stream erzähle.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ähm, und, und, Leute, wir, wir, wir wetten jetzt mal.
Wir wetten jetzt mal.
Im Stream hier, Leute.
Ja, es ist hier.
Exposed.
Also.
Ich wette mit euch.
Wenn ich, also um was, um was wetten wir?
Keine Ahnung.
Um.
Ja gut, ich kann mit euch nicht wetten, weil.
Wenn ich gewinne, krieg ich nix.
Und, ja.
Um 20 Subs, Leute.
Um 20 Subs wetten wir.
Aber was ist, wenn ich gewinne?
Da hab ich nix von.
Außer, dass ich mich geil fühlen kann.
Egal.
Ähm.
Genau, er gewinnt China US Basic.
Ich wette mit euch, Leute.
Wenn ich das Video mache, aber die Wette kann ich eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht verlieren.
Wenn ich das Video mache über Blizzard.
Und dass ich das nicht gut finde, wie sie das mit dem World Cup handhaben.
Äh, äh, äh.
Handhaben.
Und den Supporter.
Und den Support für die Spieler.
Wie heißt das Lied?
Äh.
2 Stunden 22.
Beautiful Study Work Instrumental Music Mix.
Ähm.
Genau, also ich wette mit euch.
Wenn ich dieses Video mache, über den World Cup, da ich das nicht gut finde, wie Blizzard da auch mit den Spielern umgeht und wie das organisiert ist.
Es kommt mindestens ein Blizzard Fanboy an.
Der sagt.
Magst du scheiß Blizzard Hater?
Oder, äh.
Max, du hast doch davon überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Blizzard macht das gut.
Oder, ja.
Äh.
Ah, mein Liebling.
Absolute, absolute Lieblingsaussage.
Max, Blizzard ist eine Firma, äh, Blizzard ist ein gewinnorientiertes Unternehmen und das Ziel eines gewinnorientierten Unternehmens ist es möglichst viel Gewinn zu machen.
Das ist meine Lieblingsaussage bei sowas immer.
Das ist die absolute Big Brain Aussage, ja.
Ähm.
Da könnte ich, da könnte ich mich immer aufregen, ja.
Als würde.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Leute davon haben sowas zu Fanboyen.
Das mag sein.
Das Blizzard Ziel hat, möglichst, den möglichst größten Gewinn zu machen.
Aber.
Die 750.000 Euro fallen doch überhaupt nicht auf in der Gesamtkalkulation von Blizzard.
750.000 Euro, wie gesagt, das verliert Bobby Kotick bei, in der Kantine.
Das fällt ihm aus dem Säckel, 750k.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Wir sind nicht Blizzard.
Wenn Blizzard das so macht, können wir das trotzdem scheiße finden.
Und das ist auch irgendwo das einzige, was wir machen können.
Und irgendwie mit unserer Aufgabe als Community von so einem Game, Blizzard auch zu sagen, dass wir das scheiße finden.
Einfach, einfach irgendwie Blizzard da in den Arsch zu kriechen.
Was, äh, was, was erhoffen sich die Leute eigentlich davon?
Denken die wirklich?
Die schreiben in das Video rein.
So nach dem Motto, oh, Max, Blizzard, Beste, du scheiße.
Dass dann irgendwann mal einer von Blizzard reinguckt und sagt.
Ah, der, der xx360, äh, last, äh, last nice noscoper auf YouTube hat den Max geflamed, dass er uns schlecht findet.
Haha, das ist aber ein geiler Typ.
Der kriegt jetzt drei Skins gratis.
Nein, der Typ wird niemals in seinem Leben was von haben, Blizzard gefanboyt zu haben.
Nie.
Die lachen sich höchstens über den kaputt.
Und dann wächst der Typ da.
Wenigstens einer kauft unsere Skins.
Äh, TH, Stream, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Pop.
Blablabla.
Nice.
So.
Jetzt habe ich mich genug über Blizzard und, und World Cup aufgeregt.
Aber eigentlich müssen wir das gar nicht wetten, Leute, oder?
Das ist doch, das ist doch so klar wie...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht den Standard-Kloßbrühe-Vergleich bringen.
Es ist aber klar, dass das auf jeden Fall kommen wird.
Es ist so, so klar.
Klar wie Gunner Opti, Gunner Optic Gaming Classes, äh.
Weil die sind nicht klar, die sind gelb.
Hast du was von Amazon Aero mitbekommen?
Äh.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Was ist Amazon Aero?
Aero Mesh.
Router.
Was routet der denn?
Macht der C, C Raute?
Amazon, nein, habe ich nichts von mitgekriegt.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Brand new.
990 Dollar.
E.
Aero.
Aero?
Router.
Home Mesh.
Wifi.
Coverage.
Oh.
Was?
Was ist für ein Ding?
Aero, ok!
Aero Secured & Aero Secured Plus.
Das klingt schon mal für mich nicht vertrauenserweckend.
Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas, was Amazon manńskl recommending kann oder so.
Ok, nee, keine Ahnung, ich, aber wozu braucht man das?
Was kann das mehr als ein ordentlicher U....
Rud...
Wie spricht man dés eigentlich richtig aus, man spricht Ubiquity ja nicht Ubiquity aus.
UBICUITY comments.
U U U U...
Moment.
Aussprache.
Ubiquiti, was? Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, was zum Fall? Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, okay, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, echt so beknackt aus, slow, Ubiquiti, was?
Das kann ich nicht aussprechen, das ist zu small, zu small brain habe ich dafür, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, okay, also, was kann der besser als mein Ubiquiti, äh, Access Point, ja, außer meine Daten an Amazon schicken, das ist mir klar, dass der das kann, das kann der besser als mein aktueller Access Point, ne, also,
weiß ich nicht,
weiß ich nichts zu, ehrlich gesagt, kann ich nichts zu sagen, ja, also, wenn ihr noch irgendwelche Sachen wissen wollt, haut, haut in den Chat rein, ansonsten, eigentlich wollte ich mir mit euch heute Stellenanzeigen angucken, weil es mal wieder soweit ist, haben wir schon eine ganze Weile nicht gemacht, ich habe letztens eine Stellenanzeige gesehen von, ähm, vom BKA, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das finde vom BKA, das war lustig, BKA, ähm, Jobs IT,
wo ich mal,
wo ich mal gucken, ähm, Seite sieht irgendwie kacke aus, oder, oder, oder werden irgendwelche, irgendwelche, da wird erstmal gleich der Bundestrojaner geblockt, wahrscheinlich, ähm, hä, natürlich, das ist Dienstort, das passt wieder wie die Faust aufs Auge, äh, Fachpersonal für Übersetzung in Sprachen Arabisch und Persisch, Standort Berlin, na, das war wieder klar, wobei Standort Frankfurt würde ich auch verstehen, ich erlebe ja die kulturelle Vielfalt jeden Tag,
am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt, äh, der Edgelord, Twitch Prime, Pog, ähm, das habe ich letztens, aber nicht Qualifizierungsmaßnahme, sondern, das, wahrscheinlich haben sie keinen gefunden, zumindest war das ganz merkwürdig, was die, was die, was die gesucht haben, das hat mich echt verwirrt, äh, leider finde ich das nicht mehr, vielleicht hier, Flyer, Cyberkriminalist, war das das?
Da sind merkwürdige Sachen drin, wo ich mich frage, warum muss ich als Cyberkriminal, also als IT-Mensch bei der Polizei eine Mindestgröße haben und sowas, muss ich irgendwie eine Mindestgröße haben und so, oh, alter, 33 Strahler, da bin ich, da bin ich, da bin ich zu, zu alt für, das ist aber nicht das, was ich gesehen habe, Sporttester, fuck, Alter, doch, doch, du brauchst eine Mindestgröße, jetzt bewerben, yeah, Qualifizierungsmaßnahme,
ihre, ihre Qualifikation, Größe, ja, ähm, also du musst mindestens 1,60 sein, gut, ich meine, das sollten die meisten Leute schaffen, aber, warum brauche ich als krasser Hexer irgendwie eine Mindestgröße, ach, hier sind es 42 des Lebens, ja, okay, aber 1,59, ja,
gut, Abschlussnotenabschluss, ich weiß, doch, also, mein Abschluss, mein, mein Abschlusszeugnis von der Ausbildung von vor, äh, keine Ahnung, 15, 12, äh, vielen Jahren,
ähm, der ist richtig gut, das ist irgendwie 1,2 oder so, das ist bei Berufsschule halt kackeinfaches, so, aber am besten ist, was man verdient, kriegst das hier, kriegst das hier, passt mal auf, da lacht ihr euch kaputt, was man dafür kriegt, äh,
10, Entgeltgruppe 10, ne, was so, äh, Moment, ich muss schon mal auf die Seite gucken, verdienst, hier,
ein Bezügelrechner hier, ja, also, Entgelt, E10, kriegt man da Geld, okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier für komische Stufen sind, ehrlich gesagt,
zumindest ist das fast, zumindest ist es fast nichts gewesen für das, was die wollen, was ist denn Stufe 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, was, also, das ist so eine typische, das ist echt so eine typische, äh, Amtrechenseite hier,
E10, was ist Stufe 1, 2, 3, 4,
okay, keine Ahnung, äh, zumindest, jetzt mal ehrlich, das ist, also, da musst du noch Steuern drauf bezahlen,
ich meine, hallo, 39k im Jahr, was, was, was ist das, dafür, dafür habe ich doch keine Mindestgröße und mache einen Sportkurs für 39k im Jahr, ich meine, okay, okay, man hat wahrscheinlich bessere Chancen, was,
also, bessere Konditionen,
was Krankenversicherung angeht. Wahrscheinlich muss man
insgesamt weniger Steuern bezahlen. Weiß ich nicht.
Aber guck mal hier.
Netto bleibt.
Also
wer macht das denn dafür?
wer
der wirklich
qualifiziert wäre
als krasserer Polizei-Hexor.
Also jemand,
der wirklich Ahnung hat.
Macht das nicht
39k im Jahr?
Guck mal, was man nach 5 Jahren
bekommt.
Sind das hier die Jahre oder was?
Ja, das
geht schon eher in die Richtung,
was ich mir... Das würde ich mir schon eher gefallen lassen.
Das geht
schon eher in die Richtung, wo ich sage, dass es
in Stufe... Geht das
nach Jahren oder wie funktioniert das?
Ich weiß nicht. Nach Stufe sind nicht Jahre.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Zumindest ist es insgesamt nicht viel.
Das ist jetzt
ungefähr das, was ich
gar nicht ganz...
Was ich mit 4 Tagen in der Woche kriege. Nicht ganz, wohlgemerkt.
Mit 4 Tagen in der Woche kriege.
Also, mein, the fuck?
Stimmt nicht ganz.
Aber trotzdem.
Ich meine, was die da für
Anforderungen haben.
Mindestgröße außen vor. Aber ich meine,
ich frage mich dann immer,
hat das vielleicht seinen Grund,
warum die nicht so viel qualifizierte
Leute kriegen?
Vielleicht hat das ja einen Grund.
Vielleicht denken sich nämlich richtig krass,
äh,
qualifizierte Leute, dass die keinen Bock
da drauf haben.
Also, der einzige Grund...
Achso, und dann habe ich übrigens noch einen ähnlichen Job
bei der Bundeswehr gefunden.
Die haben auch irgendwie so einen krassen, den krassen
Soldat-Hexor gesucht.
Du musst aber nicht, du musst aber
nicht mit wirklich als Soldat, sondern
wirklich als Technikmensch. So was ähnliches
haben die bei der Bundeswehr auch gesucht und es wurde auch
überhaupt nicht bezahlt.
Also, das Einzige, wie ich mir erklären
kann, dass das für
das Geld jemand macht,
ist eigentlich
nur, wenn du so der
der übertriebene, äh,
wie nennt man das in den USA?
Patriot irgendwie bist, ja?
Also, wenn du quasi einfach sagt, sie irgendwie
so, so für die
Gerechtigkeit und, und, äh,
keine Ahnung, äh,
so, für
Gerechtigkeit und Vaterland und
sonst was, dann machst du, dann nimmst du so einen Job
bei der Polizei oder bei der Bundeswehr
an für 35k im Jahr.
Aber, also,
ansonsten würde ich dem Leben nicht machen.
Warum?
Warum? Also, da musst du voller,
voller Patriot sein, ach so, das
weiß nicht, ob
es da so viel gut qualifizierte
Was ist denn heute bei einem scheiß
Mikrofon verlängert?
Geiler Wackel
da, da, fuck
MonkaS, MonkaSmoke
So,
jetzt.
Aber ansonsten würde ich das nicht machen.
Die bringen dich auch durch das Studio,
egal was ist, ja, ob das jetzt so für die Qualifizier-,
Quali-, Qualität der Leute spricht,
wenn du durch das Studium kommst, egal
was.
Naja, also, wenn die dich ordentlich bezahlen, hab ich da ja auch keine Schmerzen
mit, aber, letztendlich
arbeitet man ja nicht, ähm,
zum Arbeiten, sondern man will was
davon haben. Zumal ja auch
dazu kommt, dass eigentlich, war
der Polizei jetzt mal außen vor, ja,
mögen
auch die einen oder anderen
vielleicht fragwürdigen Sachen passieren, aber,
eigentlich müsstest du Leute, die
quasi sowas bei der Bundeswehr machen,
den müsstest du ja nochmal extra
was bezahlen. Vielleicht hat
der ein oder andere,
in der Regel sind ja IT-Leute meistens,
die meisten zumindest, relativ, ähm,
friedfertige Menschen, ja,
ähm, vielleicht
haben die auch ein bisschen was gegen
unsere Politik und gegen das, was die Bundeswehr so
macht, dass den müssten sie nochmal extra
schmerzendes Geld bezahlen.
Dass sie das machen. Die kriegen dicke
Zulagen und Prämien, ja, dann ist gut. Das ist,
das ist auch der einzige Grund, warum ich sowas mache.
Einfach nur wegen der Kohle.
Ansonsten, weil ich
irgendwie so überzeugt davon bin, bestimmt nicht.
Moin, Wauz.
810B4.
Okay, also, wir wollen jetzt mal, guck mal,
da gibt's was für mich bei Apollo Optik.
In Schwabach. Wo ist denn das?
Ich weiß nicht, wo Schwabach ist.
Du zahlst bei der Bundeswehr keine
Sozialversicherung plus keine Krankenversicherung.
Musst rein. Ja, aber du bekommst
schon ordentliche Versorgung, wenn was ist, ne?
Also, ich mein, wenn du keine Krankenversicherung bezahlst, kannst du dir
also keine Krankenversicherung oder
keine Krankenversicherung bezahlen.
Wie, wie ist das? Und dann ist das nicht schlecht.
Ja, und dann ist das, dann ist das...
Frankfurt schönste Stadt.
Frankfurt kriminellste Stadt.
Ich hab letztens in Statistik gesehen,
Frankfurt, gefährlichste
Stadt Deutschlands.
Von KS.
Ja.
Gefährlichste Städte Deutschlands.
Frankfurt.
Ja.
Die gefährlichsten 10 Städte Deutschlands.
Platz 1.
Die gefährlichste Stadt Deutschlands ist
Frankfurt am Main.
Die Bankenstadt in Hessen erreicht mit
16.292
Verbrechen pro... Ach du Scheiße.
Das ist ja echt verdammt
viel. Das ist ja schon fast ein Wunder,
dass ich da noch nicht überfallen wurde oder so.
Das ist, das ist ja übertrieben viel.
Das sind
6,25 Prozent.
Äh.
Ne.
So rechnet man das nicht, ne?
Ich bin nicht...
QuickMouse, BigShark, Alter.
Das sind 16 Prozent.
Lull.
Ach ne. Ich hätte 16 durch 100
rechnen müssen, ne? Ja.
Falsch rum. Falsch rum.
BigBrain, Alter, Leute.
BigBrain.
Ich hätte 100 durch 16 rechnen müssen.
Nicht 16 durch 100.
Äh. Nein. 16 durch 100.
Nicht 100 durch 16.
BigBrain.
16 Prozent.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
Überlegt euch mal.
Pro 100.000 Personen
werden 16 Prozent von den Verbrechen
begangen in Frankfurt. Alter, was ist da los?
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Gefährlichste Stadt in Deutschland, ne?
Im Prinzip, ja. Also,
sag mal, tief in mir wusste ich
da schon immer, dass Frankfurt kacke ist.
Also Frankfurt das übelste Drecksloch ist, ja?
Aber die Statistik haut schon echt rein.
Oh, huge host.
Frankfurt hat mich gehostet mit
279 Zuschauern.
Poggers.
Habt ihr schön getaucht.
Keine Ahnung.
Huge host.
Pog. Ja, danke für den
Host. Ich bin auch genau
eine halbe Stunde da. Ähm.
Aber Leute, ihr wollt's mir nicht glauben, ne?
Frankfurt, gefährlichste Stadt.
Haftbefehl wusste
das schon immer.
Frankfurter Ghetto, ne?
Die Kollektion Bar. Fick auf Sponsor.
Hat er schon immer gesagt, ja?
Ihr kennt sich aus.
Naja, ähm, aber wenn ich diese Statistik
sehe, muss ich sagen, ich wundere mich echt, dass ich noch nicht
überfallen wurde. Hab ich euch mal erzählt,
dass ich nen...
Die haben meinen Chef überfallen.
Also, ist schon ewig her.
Schon zehn Jahre her. Da musste ich zur
Polizei und wusste,
ähm,
wusste, dass das Portemonnaie von meinem
Chef abholen. Vor ewig,
da war ich noch Azubi, ist ewig her.
Da haben sie meinen Chef aus...
Ich muss wohl wirklich...
ausgeraubt gewesen sein, ja?
Also, der hatte nix mehr. Der hatte kein Handy
mehr danach. Der hatte keine...
Der hatte kein Portemonnaie mehr. Der hatte nix mehr danach.
Ich glaub, der hatte noch ne Jacke oder so.
Ähm, den haben sie halt auch abgerippt
am Hauptbahnhof, ja?
Und die Typen haben sie halt dann erwischt.
Und dann musste ich zur Polizei.
Also, sie haben angerufen, die Polizei,
und hat gesagt, hier, sie haben das Portemonnaie
und sowas wiedergefunden. Ist kein Geld mehr drin, aber Ausweis
und alles. Und, ähm,
da bin ich zur Polizei,
und da bin ich zum ersten Mal
in meinem Leben,
wie gesagt, schon ne ganze Weile her, in Kontakt
gekommen mit der Frankfurter Polizei.
Und das war an
Demotivation kaum zu überbieten.
Ähm,
ich bin da hingegangen,
hab am Empfang erstmal so den Typ hinterm
Panzerglas, ja, hab ich ihm
erzählt, hier, mein Name sowieso, ich soll von meinem
Chef abholen, äh, mit dem
Herr sowieso telefoniert. Der hat mir überhaupt nicht
zugehört. Der hat erstmal gesagt, hier haben Sie
einen Ausweis dabei, wollen Sie eine Anzeige aufgeben?
Nee, Moment, langsam.
Ich hab meinen Ausweis dabei, aber
ich will, ich, ich, ich
wurde nicht, ich möchte von meinem Chef das
abholen, und der Herr sowieso hat
angerufen. Das hat, der hat's nicht gecheckt.
Der war wirklich, wirklich die
Demotivation in Person.
Und irgendwann hat er's dann gecheckt,
dann ist der andere trüb runtergeratzt.
Ja, das war mein erster Kontakt mit der Frankfurter,
mit der Frankfurter Polizei.
Ansonsten hab ich echt einen guten
Eindruck von der Frankfurter Polizei.
Mein Chef, äh, nein!
Ist er nicht!
WTF?
Warum sollte der Schosslohn
sein? Hallo Kieskauer,
wir haben uns noch surft Jelly.
Kann man in der IT
über 10k verdienen?
Klar, wie ein K, also
meinst du im Monat? Nee, das wird dann schon
ein bisschen schwieriger.
Bei 10k im Jahr kannst du über allem verdienen.
Warst du schon
nachts am Hauptbahnhof? Ja, war ich.
Nachts am Hauptbahnhof, oder besser
gesagt, nachts im Hauptbahnhof
ist eigentlich
eines der sichersten Sachen
in Deutschland, würd ich fast sagen.
So viel Bahnsecurity und Polizei, wie
nachts am Hauptbahnhof unterwegs ist,
ähm,
da passiert nix. Um den Hauptbahnhof
sieht's schon ein bisschen anders aus.
Ach, er redet vom Monatslohn.
Na, so 10k im Monat in der IT sind schon
ganz schön viel. Also vielleicht,
vielleicht, bevor du Steuern
drauf bezahlst, ja.
Moselstraße, beste.
Mosel-Eck vor allem.
Mosel-Eck, Leute.
Das ist die dreckigste Kneipe, die ich je gesehen hab.
Also, von außen.
Von außen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Schaut euch an, ey.
Das ist echt,
das ist echt Frankfurter Ghetto, ey.
Da lauf ich, da lauf ich
jeden Tag vorbei, hier diese Ecke.
Da war ich nicht, da war ich noch nicht drin.
Egal. Wurscht.
Äh, ist mir nur grad eingefallen, wo's
um gefährliche Städte geht. Frankfurt ist
Nummer 1 gefährliche Städte.
Mehr, mehr gefährliche Stadt gibt's in Deutschland
nicht als Frankfurt.
Also, wenn ihr was wissen wollt, haut's in den Chat, ne?
Aber denkt immer dran, entwuppelos da vorzuschreiben.
Sonst seh ich's nicht. Ähm,
ja, der eine, du weißt schon, vollkommen
normal in Frankfurt, er schreibt grad in den Chat,
wurde an der Flixbus-Haltestelle
zweimal von Leuten auf
Heroin auf Englisch angelabert, ob ich ne Kippe hätte.
Ja, das ist, das ist normal in Frankfurt.
Letztens sind wir Mittagessen gegangen, da hat
grad einer irgendwie zwei, zwei Mädels überfallen
und so, das ist halt Frankfurt.
Ja.
Vor allem, vor allem Kaiserstraße,
Taunusstraße, da hinten in der Ecke.
Naja. Ähm,
Offenbach. Ja,
Offenbach ist gar nicht so wild. Offenbach
hat nen ziemlich hohen Ausländeranteil, aber auch
nicht überall. Frankfurt ist,
Frankfurt ist im Prinzip schon schlimmer.
Offenbach mag auf den ersten
Blick schlimmer sein, aber
unterm Strich ist Frankfurt schlimmer.
Wir werden sicher bald abgerippt, ja genau.
Würdest du es empfehlen,
nach Frankfurt zu ziehen? Nö. Das ist übelst
teuer, es ist scheiße in, also
es sackt, direkt in Frankfurt
zu sein.
Es ist übelst teuer
und, ähm,
anbindungsmäßig, je nachdem wo du bist, bist du auch
nicht schneller auf der Arbeit. Wärst du
bereit für einen Job woanders hinzuziehen?
Wenn die mir so viel bezahlen würden, dass ich
das mit meinem Haus hier lohnen würde, dann schon, aber
äh, wird mir wahrscheinlich
keiner so viel bezahlen.
Wie lange pendelst du da ungefähr, ungefähr?
Naja, ich lauf ja immer vom Südbahnhof hoch
über, äh, in die Innenstadt.
Das dauert ne halbe Stunde.
Also wenn du das, wenn du das mit dazu nimmst, bin ich
ungefähr ne Stunde unterwegs von Tür zu
Tür. Aber wenn ich reine, reine Fahrzeit,
reine Fahrzeit mit dem Zug
würde ich sagen, so, äh,
20 Minuten.
Und dann noch ne U-Bahn
irgendwie 5 Minuten. Bin ne Stunde unterwegs,
weil ich halt morgens und mittags ein Stückchen
laufe, da ich mich überhaupt mal am Tag bewege.
Ob kreisend für dich, ja, Emotes
machen wir alle, Emotes.
Übrigens, Leute, hab ich euch schon erzählt, ja, ich hab den,
ich hab heute noch nicht einmal den Sellout gestartet.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, was ihr tolles mit eurem Amazon
Prime Account machen könnt? Falls ihr das noch
nicht wusstet. Ihr könnt euren Amazon
Prime mit Twitch, äh, mit euren Amazon Prime
Account mit Twitch verbinden und einen Streamer
eurer Wahl einmal im
Monat mit einem Tier 1 Sub unterstützen.
Ihr habt alle Vorteile, die ein normaler
Sub hat. Der Streamer hat auch
alle Vorteile, die ein normaler Sub, äh,
bringt. Die einzigen, die geilen
Geld sehen, ist Twitch und Amazon. Also,
da gibt's eigentlich nix lang zu überlegen.
Und es verlängert sich nicht automatisch, ne?
Kein, kein Skamars Abo
Flatrate.
Endlich mal ein Sellout, ne? Kannst du
das? Nee, nee.
Braucht, braucht mir nix. Aber
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel Richtung Hauptbahnhof ist
nachts gar nicht so wild.
Ähm, ich glaube, es liegt zum
also, ich will nicht sagen, dass da nix ist, aber
je nachdem, wo das ist, ist es gar nicht so wild,
weil, ähm, also
Bahnhofsviertel nicht, die, die Straßen zum Hauptbahnhof
sind manchmal, oder meistens nachts nicht so wild,
weil mittlerweile
sind dort, wo früher die ganzen
Rotlicht-Geschichten waren,
also ich mein, die halbe Kaiserstraße ist mittlerweile
Friseure, Dönerläden,
äh, türkische Gemüseläden und sowas
in der Richtung. Und die haben alle Security vor
ihren Läden stehen nachts.
Ezo abonniert Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Pock.
Was hältst du davon, dass alle Handys die Klinke
abschaffen? Total beknackt.
Ich hab jetzt auch so eins. Ich hab jetzt ein iPhone,
äh,
10? Ist XR?
R10?
X-Files, zwei Monate aktuell im Fortlauf, äh,
was, äh, zwei Monate aktuell im ersten
fortlaufenden Monat. Big-Brain-Sub.
M-Alert 4, Twitch Prime.
Jetzt geht's aber ab hier.
Der IQ vom Chat steigt
beachtlich mit jedem Sub, ne.
Mal angemerkt.
Hast du nach deiner Informatikausspielung noch studiert?
Nein. Wie findest du
Fieldsupport?
Du meinst jemand, der vor Ort zu den
Leuten hinfährt und da irgendwelche Dinger repariert?
Ich find generell jeglichen Endkundensupport
ätzend. Alpcorn hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Was hältst du von
Custom Rooms? Ja, ich, ich würd mir wünschen,
dass es für manche Tablets, die ich habe,
ein ordentliches Custom Room gibt.
Ich mag ja den Spruch, haste Prime,
baller ihn rein. Das hört sich
für mich eher Cup of Pride an.
Naja, aber eigentlich wollten wir ein paar
Anzeigen angucken.
Wir haben jetzt leider nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit, aber
guck mal, was es gibt, ja.
DevOps Engineer bei
in Nürnberg. Na, Nürnberg ist mir
ein bisschen weit weg, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wir können ja mal kurz gucken, was sie schreiben.
Apollo Optik.
Was wollen sie denn haben?
Wisst ihr, was ich an dieser Stellenanzeige schon
mal ziemlich gut finde, ohne dass ich jetzt
näher gelesen hab?
Dass die nicht anfangen mit
Wir sind der größte, beste,
tollste und Marktführer im Bereich
XY.
Weil so Stellenanzeigen geben mir immer auf den Keks.
Die sich den ersten Abschnitt erstmal komplett selber
loben müssen.
Wann kommt das Video zum
über den gerouteten Staubsauger?
Naja, ein Video über den Staubsauger an sich mach ich nicht.
Ich mach ein Video, wo ich versuche Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger
laufen zu bringen.
Guck mal, ob das funktioniert.
Im Livestream ein frisches Android auf dein Tablet portieren.
Wir portieren nicht.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr im Livestream mal
ein Tablet routen. Oder ein Tablet flashen.
Können wir mal machen.
Was wir nicht machen werden, ist das Amazon Fire Tablet flashen.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen, Twitch ist von Amazon.
Und ich glaube,
Amazon ist nicht so scharf drauf,
dass man seine Fire Tablets routet.
Vor allem live im Stream.
Wie hast du dich nach deiner Ausbildung
weitergebildet, bzw. was kannst du empfehlen?
Bin ich
nach eineinhalb Jahren fertig und mach schon
ne Cisco Netzwerkkunst? Ist doch gut.
Also, ich hab ja
angefangen quasi bei einem
Provider, hab ich euch ja erzählt.
Ähm,
jetzt bin ich da, wo ich schon ne Weile bin.
Von da bin ich ja dann gewechselt.
Ähm, dort wo ich jetzt bin.
Da bin ich jetzt ja auch schon wieder ne ganze Weile.
Ähm,
also die beste Weiterbildungsvariante
ist tatsächlich,
sich selbst weiterzubilden
in nem Bereich, den
man, der einem gefällt.
Weil nur, wenn man in nem Bereich wirklich
Spaß hat, oder in nem Bereich hat, der
einem gefällt, nur dann wird man auch richtig gut in dem Bereich.
Man kann, deswegen, das finde ich
bei diesen Motivationsvideos auf YouTube immer
doof, ne? So nach dem Motto, die,
naja, ihr kennt ja diese Sachen, so nach dem Motto, ich komm mit
nem fetten Auto reingefahren, oder so nach dem Motto,
mit diesem einfachen Trick, 50 Millionen, bla,
easy life, easy lifestyle am Strand.
Ähm, die tun immer so,
so nach dem Motto, alter, mach was,
überbinde dich, äh, äh,
streng dich an, kauf mal ein Zeug, ich hab Visionen,
alter, ähm,
es halte ich persönlich für totalen
Schwachsinn, irgendwas zu machen, was
man kacke findet. Wenn man, wenn man sich
zu irgendwas zwingt,
wenn man sich dazu zwingen muss, was
zu machen, wird man da nie richtig gut werden.
Man wird nur richtig gut in dem Bereich, der einen
eh interessiert, und dadurch,
dass auch der, dass einen der Bereich interessiert,
wird man auch immer besser in dem jeweiligen Bereich.
Und umso besser man wird in diesem jeweiligen
Bereich, umso höher ist die Chance, dass du natürlich
auch später in diesem Bereich,
ähm, arbeiten kannst, weil
du dich eben richtig gut auskennst.
Also, next level. Richtig
big brain, also das Beste ist wirklich
in dem Bereich, der dir Spaß macht,
und der dir gefällt, einfach,
dich komplett immer weiter
ins Detail, äh, die Richtung,
wo es dir gefällt, einzuarbeiten, ja.
Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger, das mache ich noch.
Doch, doch.
Was hast du eigentlich von deiner FISI
Ausbildung gelernt? Oh, naja, das natürlich nicht.
Ja, mittlerweile schon Line, äh,
Lineage OS auf dem Fire Tablet, das habe ich gesehen.
Oh, ich wollte mein,
ich habe ja, äh, mir
letztes Jahr Weihnachten habe ich mir
Fire HD 10s gekauft,
eins habe ich schon, bisschen entschlackt von Amazon,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie weit das
die scharf drauf sind, sowas im Stream erzählt,
und das nächste werde ich auch Lineage, Lineage
Dings da drauf flashen.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt, müsst ihr immer in Wupplos
schreiben, neunteilung, sonst sehe ich es nicht.
Man muss halt 40 plus Jahre
arbeiten, ist doof, weil man keinen Bock hat, nur muss man
nicht. Wenn man natürlich
das Geld, das Geld zum Fenster rausschmeißt,
wenn man einen ganz guten
Job hat, dann muss man 40 Jahre arbeiten.
Es gibt einen YouTube Channel,
wo angeblich die Programmierfragen in einem
Vorstellungsgespräch
nachgespielt werden.
Wie realistisch sind solche Videos?
Keine Ahnung, kenne ich nicht.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Wollen wir uns das mal angucken?
Ich kenne das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Wie heißt das?
Interview IO?
Ah, das ist auf
Englisch, okay.
Weiß ich nicht, was haben die so zu
Python Interview
Netflix Engineer
Binary Array Partition
Ah
Sollte es nicht, ja, sollte es nicht
eher Binary Search
heißen?
Was soll denn?
Also entweder bin ich schon mal nicht
Big Brain genug, um überhaupt den Titel zu
verstehen, das könnte schon mal nicht
zu Netflix, oder sie meinen wirklich
Binary Search in einem sortierten Array.
Okay, war es auch immer.
Ist ja nur Python.
C plus O
I
Vielleicht auch was,
wo ich was sagen kann. Ich meine,
ich kann Python lesen und schreiben, aber ich bin jetzt nicht der übelste Python
Pro.
C++
AWS Engineer
Technical Interview
Google Engineer
Added Distance String Comparison
Jetzt würden sie aber Zeug wissen, ey.
Beating Hour Optimation,
wenn man sowas schon braucht.
Missing Item Difference
Regular Expression Evaluator
Oh, das ist was für mich. Regular
Expressions ist ja eh schon generell für absolut
die Big Brainston Leute überhaupt,
ne? Ihr kennt ja den alten
Flachwitz. Willst du ein Problem mit
Regex lösen, dann hast du zwei Probleme.
JavaScript Interview
Das ist jetzt leider ein bisschen
zu lang, dass wir uns das angucken können.
Aber wenn es, also ich
gebe, also wenn ich das so lese,
das wird wahrscheinlich nicht komplett aus der Luft
gegriffen sein. Aber wo
die auf jeden Fall total drauf stehen,
das habe ich auch schon gehört. Wie gesagt, ich habe noch
keinen Test irgendwie bei Google oder so gemacht, ne?
Ähm, was ich auch
schon gehört habe, dass die total
scharf drauf sind, dass du so
diese Basic,
wie sagt man so, Basic Computer Science
Geschichten kannst, ja?
Dass du einen Quicksort verstehst,
oder dass du
Binary Search erklären kannst,
dass du zum Beispiel erklären kannst,
ja, Preisfrage an euch Leute.
Warum kann eine
Suchmaschine,
oder, ich nenn's
mal Suchmaschine, ja?
Warum kann eine Suchmaschine,
eine gescheite Suchmaschine,
ähm,
warum unterstützen
die keine Wildcards
am Anfang des Wortes?
Big Brain Frage.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal nicht Google, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt
ordentlich Wildcards unterstützen, die machen sehr viel
Magic im Hintergrund. Nehmen wir mal sowas wie
Lucene oder Elasticsearch.
Warum, warum,
warum kann, können die nicht, ich
weiß, sie können es, aber warum können sie
es nicht schnell, ähm,
Wildcards am Anfang des Wortes?
Was ist eine Wildcard?
Eine Wildcard ist sowas zum Beispiel.
Ja, Dungeon
Ick-o-Soft.
So, was ist eine Wildcard? So nach dem Motto,
am Anfang
alles, was, egal mit was es anfängt
und dann Ick-o-Soft kommt. Das ist eine Wildcard.
Weil das den Index fickt, ja, das
ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Es ist im Prinzip ganz einfach zu erklären, warum
äh, Suchmaschinen keine Wildcards am Anfang
unterstützen. Und zwar,
Suchmaschinen sind in der Regel,
machen wir das jetzt mal ganz kurz,
Suchmaschinen sind in der Regel, oder
der Index von einer Suchmaschine,
äh, ist im Prinzip
ein sortiertes
Array. Sortiert
ist wichtig. Warum ist sortiert
wichtig? Dass man Binary Search
machen kann. Und warum ist das wichtig?
Naja, weil man nicht unbedingt
den kompletten, nicht alles
unbedingt immer im RAM haben will, beziehungsweise
nicht alle Details,
ja. Man möchte vielleicht den Index im RAM,
haben. Also man hat eine Liste
mit ganz viel Zeug drin, A, B, C,
A, D, C, A, D, C, A, D.
Egal, ne.
So, mit allen möglichen Wörtern
sortiert, die in allen
möglichen Dokumenten gefunden wurden.
So, und wenn ich da drüber jetzt
Binary Search mache,
ich kann, ich kann kein Binary Search machen,
wenn ich den Anfang des Wortes nicht kenn.
Deswegen können
search, deswegen können, ähm,
deswegen können,
äh, sowas wie Elasticsearch und
Suchmaschinen keine Wildcards am Anfang.
Binary Search ist ja im Prinzip
diese, diese Teile-und-Herrsche-Geschichte.
So nach dem Motto, ich gucke,
ich geh in die Mitte, ich geh in die Mitte,
guck, ist das, was ich suche, größer oder kleiner?
Dann nehm ich das Nächste in die Mitte,
guck, ist das größer oder kleiner?
Und nach Log-In-Zeit
hab ich dann das gefunden,
was ich suche. So.
Und deswegen gehen keine Wildcards
am Anfang. Ganz einfach,
oder? Doch.
Machen Binary Search.
Ähnliche Affe, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nur, dass es, ich dachte, es ist Log-In.
Ich, ich bin mir jetzt,
bin mir jetzt auch nicht ganz sicher, aber,
ähm,
ist, das ist schon alles,
das ist schon ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, das ist wie bei, Telefonbuch ist
ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür.
Telefonbuch ist ja auch sortiert.
Also ich find diese Methode,
ehrlich gesagt, schon ziemlich clever, Flying Bullets.
Also mir fällt nichts besseres ein,
als Kombination aus quasi,
ähm,
vom Aufbau der Datei und wie schnell du was findest.
Sortiert und Binary Search.
Das Einzige, was mir noch schnell,
also so, von Basic, von Ansätzen her,
das Einzige, was mir noch einfallen würde, ist natürlich,
du könntest da quasi
so ein Wörterbuch draus bauen, ja, aber
dann hast du das Problem, dass du halt
groß wirst.
Binary Search in der Datei kannst du halt auch
super, super schön und schnell machen, weil du
nur sehr selektiv die Datei lesen musst.
Und ich mein, so ein Index wie Google, ich weiß nicht,
ob der komplett ins RAM passt, wahrscheinlich,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ist bei Google auch vom
Internet. Aber ich find Binary Search
eigentlich so das, Binary Search
ist übrigens auch das, wenn man, wenn man das
irgendwo lernt, how to, how to
Suchmaschinen programmieren, ist das erste,
was du beigebracht kriegst, äh,
Index, Postings und Binary Search.
Du kannst da mit Sicherheit noch ein bisschen
parallelisieren und sonst was, ja.
Egal. Nur, nur so
viel, deswegen können Suchmaschinen
keine Wildcards am Anfang und
wenn sie's können, dann
ist das langsam. Weil dann wird
kein Binary Search mal gemacht, sondern
linear, dass der komplette
Index durchsucht,
ähm, nach Wörtern, die passen.
Hat übrigens mit Regex nix zu tun.
Regex ist für, äh, Wörter im
Index suchen nicht unbedingt, das ist ja nix.
Hehehe. Äh,
Mattes, ich wollt's jetzt ja bloß mal ansprechen.
Eigentlich wollt ich jetzt gar nicht so im Detail
irgendwelche Suchmaschinen erzählen.
Naja, zumindest, äh, wir wollen uns eigentlich weiter
Job, Jobanzeigen an.
Hey Max, ich arbeite
seit zwei Jahren als Quereinsteiger
in der IT. Ich lese
gleich weiter, ich muss nur mal kurz gucken, ob ich oben was verpasst
hab. Ähm,
okay, hey Max, ich arbeite seit zwei Jahren
als Quereinsteiger in der IT.
Ich komm gut klar und es macht sehr viel
Spaß. Das ist nice.
Ähm, ich kann ja mit
4,5 Jahren Berufserfahrung einfach die
IHK Prüfung machen, ja, kannst du glaub ich.
Allerdings weiß ich nicht, ob ich mir
eventuelle Basics dann fehlen, äh,
äh. Was ist
deine Meinung dazu? Ich bin 30 Jahre alt und würde mich
stark entscheiden mit dem
Ausbildungsgehalt, würde ich. Äh, wenn du,
wenn du die Prüfung machen kannst, mach das.
Ähm, dir fehlen keine Basics. Die IHK
Prüfung, also die IHK Ausbildung
ist, äh, für den Arsch.
Ja, du kannst, du kannst
das, was du wissen musst,
offensichtlich ja, sonst wärst du nicht 4,5
Jahre dabei.
Das, das
Schwierige bei der IHK Prüfung
ist nicht die Ausbildung,
sondern, dass man versteht, wie
die IHK Prüfungsfragen
dargestellt und wenn man
jemand hätte, der 3 Jahre
Ausbildung gemacht hätte,
gegenüber jemand, der einfach
nur 6 Wochen für die IHK Prüfung gelernt hat,
der da keine Ahnung von Tuten und Blasen
hat, aber 6 Wochen für die IHK Prüfung
gelernt hat, wird besser abschneiden. Das heißt,
das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist, dich für den
Krempel anmelden, weil, wie gesagt,
ich weiß, dass es nach einer gewissen Zeit geht, ich wusste jetzt nicht,
dass es 4,5 Jahre sind.
Meldest dich einfach an,
besorgst dir ein paar Beispielprüfungen,
gibt's genug im Internet.
Von den letzten Jahren, die offiziellen Prüfungen
von den letzten Jahren. Ich würde mir gar keine
Sachen von diesen Fake-Prüfungen besorgen.
Ich würde mir einfach im Internet
auf einschlägig bekannten Seiten
die IHK Prüfung
der letzten Jahre besorgen.
Wir müssten übrigens mal echt eine IHK Prüfung
machen oder so.
Und dann ist gut.
Dann lernst du das mal ein bisschen und dann machst
du die Prüfung mit Links, gehe ich mal von aus.
Jung... Jung... WURREN!
Auch ein Name.
Max, ich bin ein IT-Nope.
Was ist ein Active Directory?
Das ist Windows-Zeug.
Da bin ich der Falsche für.
Ich könnte das versuchen zu erklären.
Aber Windows-Zeug hatte ich heute schon genug.
Mal ein bisschen off-topic.
Was sind deine Erfahrungen damit,
als Physiker im Informatik-Bereich
zu arbeiten?
Naja, nachdem ich kein Physiker bin,
habe ich auch keine Erfahrung, wie es als Physiker ist,
im Informatik-Bereich zu arbeiten.
Moin, Max. Heute schön auf die Bahn gewartet.
Nee, ich habe nicht auf die Bahn gewartet.
Ich habe in der Bahn drinnen gesessen
und musste übelst kacken.
Und das Ding hat eine halbe Stunde rumgezuckelt
und rumgetrödelt.
Ist die IHK-Prüfung wirklich so geschenkt,
wie bei einem Umklick?
Das einzige Schwierige an IHK-Prüfungen ist,
zu verstehen, was sie wissen wollen.
Max, was hältst du davon,
bei den Big Four im IT-Bereich anzufangen?
Ja, warum nicht?
Ich meine, Wirtschaftsprüfungsdinger sind nicht unbedingt
das, wo ich schon immer mal geträumt habe,
wenn die Leute okay sind,
wenn
die Kohle stimmt
und die ganze Gestaltung drumherum. Warum nicht?
Was ist ein realistischer Verdienst
als DevOps-Engineer?
Die Internetzahlen sind ja meistens Bullshit.
Nee, du kannst dir beispielsweise
die letzte Stack-Overflow-Umfrage angucken.
Da kriegst du zumindest
halbwegs realistische...
Die gibt es ja sogar auch nach Deutschland eingeteilt.
Oder die CT macht auch Gehaltsumfragen.
Kannst du dir angucken.
Die sind nicht realistisch.
Es kommt in Deutschland auch sehr auf die Region an.
Also Frankfurt
kannst du schon irgendwas um 60-70k
je nachdem, um was es für einen Bereich geht.
60-70k in dem Dreh.
70k
je nachdem, was es ist.
Vielleicht sogar mehr.
Je nachdem, was es ist und welcher Laden das ist.
Und welche Region.
Die IHK-Prüfungen sind ein Witz. Richtig.
Ich fand die IHK-Prüfung absolut behindert
von der Fragestellung. Ist sie auch.
Jupp. Ist sie auch.
Ey Max, wie hoch schätzt du im Raum Frankfurt
das Einstiegsgehalt eines Dualstudenten
wirtschaftlich... Kein Schirm.
Honka Windows. Ja, beste.
Hast du schon Youtube-Kommentare gelesen?
Ne, ich hab mich über Overwatch aufgeregt
und dann haben wir uns über irgendwas anderes unterhalten
und jetzt ist es 21.45 Uhr.
Max, nie wieder Sex
oder nur Windows für alles?
Ich würde sagen nie wieder Sex,
weil, also wenn es wirklich nur die zweite Aussage gibt,
weil unter Windows
kann man sich noch nicht mal trauen auf Porn-Seiten zu gehen.
Unter anderem im Betriebssystem
ist das ja noch möglich. Da muss man sich nicht
gleich Gedanken machen, dass man sich was einfängt.
Magst du nochmal den CD-Sampler
der Windows 98 CD anschauen?
Unter Spiele gibt es nämlich noch Spiellebens.
Können wir mal machen, irgendwann demnächst.
Wo hast du denn den
Naisu-Sound her? Das ist eine koreanische
Text-to-Speech-Engine, die das macht.
Die kann auch mehr.
Die kann zum Beispiel auch sagen
oder, oder
oder
mein Lieblingssatz,
den er sagt, den kann ich leider nicht so oft sagen,
wie ich ihn gerne sagen würde.
Und das hier ist auch nice.
Berlusius, dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Tagst du öfters?
Es wäre schon
schlimm wenn ich ja ich komme dem chat kann ich hinterher eine meinung zum informatik techniker
was ist das meinst du so was wie die heißen staatlich geprüfter bla bla bla assistent
oder so das ist das ist was war dein abschluss projekt der ausbildung vpn layer 2 open vpn
zwischen zwei standorten müssten physis am ende der ausbildung ein projekt man ja klar hast du
eigene personalverantwortung führungskräfte bekommen ja noch mal mehr kohle das wird
führungskräfte mehr kohle ist sag mal so markt in deutschen unternehmen recht verbreitet sein
aber mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr pauschal so die meisten unternehmen jetzt hier in deutschland
haben langsam auch gecheckt dass für viele leute die in der technik arbeiten die dass die auch nach
kennengelernt werden und die auch nach kennengelernt werden und die auch nach kennengelernt werden
und die auch nach kennengelernt werden und die auch nach kennengelernt werden und die auch nach
karrieremöglichkeiten suchen aber absolut abgrundtief keinen bock auf management haben
deswegen gibt es immer mehr unternehmen und die großen auf jeden fall mittlerweile auch schon
durchgängig dass du entwicklungs und karrieremöglichkeiten hast auch in der technik
ohne führungskraft werden zu müssen aber ganz ordentlich was verdienen aber es ist eigentlich
scheißegal unterm strich du musst was können was gebraucht wird und nicht so ein allerwelts zeug
es ist natürlich gut wenn man alle welt zeug auch kann aber nur wenn man sich richtig gut in einem bereich auskennt oder richtig gut in mehreren bereichen auskennt besser als irgendwie jeder da hergelaufen windows ad admin dann darauf kommt es an dann verdienst du auch kohle so muss das können wir's nicht viele können
die ak prüfung immer so zwanghaft eingedeutscht warum suchst du auf goal in die shops weil es
dort immer die lustigsten job anzeigen gibt alte partner schaffen vielleicht soll ich sie mal vielleicht soll ich die
echt mal fragen ja oft aber hast du noch kontakt zu kabu ganz ganz selten bis ich
muss mich da mal wieder melden bist du eigentlich häufig mit vpn unterwegs achtest du auf deine
privaten daten im netz besonders stark hast feier sex twitch prime dankeschön
oder steckst du gesehen habe ja wenn ihr super krasse an warum bin ich jetzt eigentlich stehen
geblieben hier in im chat ich bin nicht mehr durch das feier sex hatten wir gerade schon
aus dem start dann findet es ab noch nicht entstehen geblieben ja also falls ihr die
top stelle für einen der fox engineer schlechthin habt ja dann sagt mir bescheid ich will zwar nicht
unbedingt wechseln
ich will überhaupt nicht wechseln aber ich bin für jedes angebot zu haben wer das ernsthaft
machen will meine meine e mail adresse findet ihr auf meinem youtube channel einfach auf kanal info
ich bin ja ich bin nichts abgeneigt ja es muss auch kein der fox engineer ist ja eh so eine
beklagte bezeichnung ja das kann ich nicht wissen ob die stelle so heißt unterm strich oder nicht
ist mir vollkommen wurscht auf was soll ich mich konzentrieren vielleicht auch noch selbstständig
oder nicht ist mir vollkommen wurscht auf was soll ich mich konzentrieren vielleicht auch noch selbstständig
erlernen wenn ich als it system elektroniker im bereich netzwerktechnik nach der ausbildung
arbeiten will weil das was man da lernt ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn legit anna score zwei monate
solange am start bist werden eigentlich auch leute gesucht die rast können selten holy astra rakete twitch
prime
im chat ist wirklich passive hat mal gandhi twitch prime auch zwei monate am start das geht aber ab heute
man hat mal gandhi twitch prime auch zwei monate am start das geht aber ab heute
warum chrome größer firefox finde ich nicht benutze immer noch lieber firefox bei der bahn suchen wir immer noch ich weiß nicht da müsste ich echt schon viel schmerzensgeld kriegen
warum chrome größer firefox bei der bahn suchen wir immer noch viel schmerzensgeld kriegen
was hältst du von der neuordnung der it beruf habe ich gar nichts von mitgekriegt alter wie viele subs hast du jetzt also vorhin hatte ich 366
warum hängst du so sehr hinterher im chat weil der chat so viel ist heute wobei eigentlich ist der chat immer so viel ich komme nie richtig hinterher
du als devops pro hast du dich schon mal mit istio beschäftigt service man nein habe ich nicht
gratis bahncard dinge das bringt mir ja auch nichts wenn es nicht funktioniert
ich habe schon ein jobticket was relativ günstig ist
it in der db ist wirklich super
kann ich mir vorstellen wo ist die miet die liegt irgendwo auf dem schrank
ich kann mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass die it in der bahn gar nicht üben
was hältst du vom schlagwort security plus devops du meinst ein devsecops
gibt es ja so wortkreationen mittlerweile
jeder der ein bisschen was mit
also egal ob es ein security oder ein devsecops ist
ob anwendungsentwickler oder administrator oder eben so ein zwischen ding oder ein full stack irgendwas quickscope hd developer oder sonst was
jeder hat sollte heutzutage was mit security am hut haben
schon schon mit ubiquiti ich hab's gelernt leute
routern gearbeitet ja hab ich
allerdings nicht viel
morgen geht die programmiervorlesung los welche tipps hast du für den ce einstieg
eigentlich würde ich jetzt sagen nichtンパ
würde ich jetzt sagen nicht mit c einsteigen aber wenn du keine andere möglichkeit hast alter was
gibt was gibt es für tipps pc einzusteigen ja nicht unter windows wobei wir schon so
leicht keine schlechte idee ist muss es wirklich c sein wird nämlich mit zehn nicht einsteigen
schau mal die bit jobs okay mag leute sind 124 muss gleich oft bin ich bilingual wenn ich deutsch
und russ kann ja wenn ein deutsch nicht so eingerostet ist das war schlecht oder stelle
als minecraft server an dem ok der chief warum nicht also ich kann mir vorstellen dass bei der
bahn nicht schlecht ist ja lachs der es so ist das c und c++ c ist auf jeden fall von beiden
sprachen die bessere zu lernen c++ es gibt auf der welt nicht einen der c++ wirklich kann noch
nicht mal der c++ erfinder
keiner kann richtig c++ selbst die komitee leute nicht c ist definitiv die einfache sprache davon
allerdings auch keine gute einstiegssprache ist eine super einstiegssprache ruby ist super mit
c sharp kann man auch schon anfangen meinetwegen sogar mit java oder wenn man browser sachen machen
will javascript aber fast alles außer google go zum beispiel auch an ganz gute sprache zum einstieg
maxi findest du den brave browser ziemlich gut habe ich letztens ausprobiert auf dem iphone
eingebaut der adblock kann das einzige was mir jetzt
noch fehlt ist aber ich glaube da soll etwas mit ios 13 kommen dass man im hintergrund was
abspielen kann sampler genau könnt ihr euch daran erinnern wo wir sampler im stream programmiert
haben das war echt massive woodface bauen um 5 aufstehen weil die schulung geht ja bis 17 uhr
da komme ich ein bisschen später auf die arbeit wie waren youtube kommentaren haben
nicht einen youtube kommentar gelesen und noch mal erst mal die schulung mit
kommentare gelesen habe aktionen für einen spieler neuer auf ich habe noch einen kommentar gelesen und erst mal
kommentare gelesen und erst mal kommentare gelesen und erst mal kommentare gelesen und erst mal
eine Stellenanzeige angeguckt, weil wir mit
allem möglichen im anderen beschäftigt waren.
Und der Chat auch
sehr viel wissen will heute irgendwie.
C-Vorlesung, 70% Durchfallrate.
Ja, C.
Eigentlich gibt es an C gar nicht so
viel Features.
C kann ja im Endeffekt fast nix.
Also an eingebauten Features.
Ich meine, du kannst mit C alles machen.
Aber du kannst dich halt ziemlich schnell in den Fuß schießen.
Aha, ist doch hier dran.
Das ist doch mal was. Wusste ich nicht.
Wie läuft es mit den Weibern?
Mir ist eine Sache aufgefallen.
Ihr wisst ja,
ich bin nicht so
unbedingt der große Deutsch-Rap-Fan.
Aber ich hab
gestern, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
ausholen, ja, also
zu dieser Frage, okay.
Ich hab gestern
auf Twitter ein Video gesehen, wo sie irgendwie
irgendeinen Rapper festgenommen haben,
weil er ohne Führerschein gefahren ist
oder sowas. Und da hab ich
mir mal wieder Gedanken gemacht,
zu deutschen
Rapp und deutschen Hip-Hop.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ich eigentlich
überhaupt
mich
null identifizieren kann
mit deutschem Hip-Hop
und dem
Inhalt vom deutschen Hip-Hop.
Bis auf eine Sache.
Das hab ich bei Farid Bang
und Kollegen schon öfters gehört.
Da geht es ums Mütterficken.
Und 35 hast ja nicht mal so viel
äh...
viele alternativen das ist glaube ich das einzige thema mit dem ich mich mit
deutschem hip hop identifizieren kann
das war es dann aber auch man beachte die mehrzahl ansonsten ist das nichts
für mich du fanboy ach gott ey das ist so eine peinliche aktion
so eine ultra peinliche aktion vor allem hat es sich ja wohl angeblich
mittlerweile bei der berliner polizei entschuldigt habe ich gelesen
zuerst irgendwie groß auf twitter herum getönt und nach dem motto ich für alle
alle alles scheiß fanboys ihr habt ihr habt nur internet eier bei was was ist
ein internet eier eigentlich so problematisch ich meine internet eier
heißt ja im endeffekt neuland eier und neuland eier ist fast schon bio und bio
ist in der heutigen zeit nur wirklich kein keine keine beleidigung mehr
und jetzt hat jetzt hat er den übelsten rückzieher
gemacht und sich irgendwie noch bei der polizei entschuldigt ist übelst dumm ja
ich weiß gar nicht wie weltfremd du im kopf sein musst überhaupt um da irgendwie
solche sprüche zu ich meine ich fand ich fand es ja teilweise irgendwie ganz
witzig muss ich sagen ja ich weiß es ist unter aller sau da müssen wir nicht von
reden ich fand schon lustig wo dann wo am ende die blonde polizistin kam wo er
irgendwie angefangen hat mit irgendwie wer bist du du zwerg ich weiß es ist unter aller sau ja
und es ist wahrscheinlich der übelste spaß hat der muss dich kurz lachen
zumindest da habe ich mir gedacht ok 1 eigentlich sollte es nicht verlachen
hast du eigentlich mitbekommen dass kollege alles gelöscht hat auf youtube
und useless mit überhaupt nicht da müsste sich meine post transformation
fürs brain ausdenken das wäre mal was und hier
massive brain gibt wo die polizei flehr auf twitter mit abgewandten bushido line gefEpedet haben ich nicht das kanal dimensional
gibt wo die polizei flehr auf knit mit abgewandten bushido line gef belt haben nicht
wo die polizei flare auf dinner mit abgewandten bushido line gefpedelt haben loss z.b dieses
wo die bemannz frequencies features unter uns und jetzt habe ich hier abs bisschen burschen und ein likerrec conventions und totale defmiehr im im modus und einfach abreden und taking all accounts.
Shido-Line gefickt. Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Hab ich nicht gesehen. Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab nur die
Videos geguckt, ne.
Wie bescheuert
kann man sein, ne. Wie bescheuert
kann man sein. Vor allem,
ähm, der hat ja
dann, der hat ja dann so, der ist ja danach auf,
ist richtig dumm eigentlich, ne. Der ist ja
danach auf Twitter und hat dann noch ein bisschen
die Leute rumbeleidigt,
die sich, ähm, über das Video
lustig
gemacht haben, ja.
So nach dem Motto, oh scheiß
Internet-Eier, heul doch.
Ganz ehrlich, ähm,
wenn man auf sowas, wenn man auf
sowas die, die, die Aussage
kriegt, ey, alter, heul doch,
dann würde ich, würde ich drauf sagen, ja,
ich heul halt aus Freude, weil ich es so geil
finde, dass ich es nicht fertig gemacht habe, ja.
Weil ich weiß nicht, wie man da auf Twitter, warum man
so
bescheuert ist, danach auch noch
dann auf die eigenen Fans loszugehen.
Ich mein,
letztendlich,
waren sie auf dicke Hose,
mit, mit, mit fettem Auto,
fette Kohle, die sie haben, aber
gerade durch die Fans haben sie doch die Kohle.
Warum macht man
seine eigenen Fans an?
Das ist genauso, wie Kollege irgendwie mal so ein Typ
von der Bühne gekickt hat, ja,
oder halt von der Bühne gekickt hat.
Die sind doch nur da, weil sie solche Leute überhaupt haben.
Wie kann man,
wie kann man wirklich seine eigenen Fans,
ich mein, ich hab auch Spasten auf YouTube, ja.
Ich bann, ich bann
auch Leute, die sich übelst,
daneben benehmen.
Natürlich, ja, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich
auf YouTube jemanden banne, oder
ob du dem erstmal das Bein,
das Bein in den Bauch legst, ja.
Und letztendlich
die Leute, die auf ein Konzert gehen, ja, und das
und da das abfeiern,
das sind wahrscheinlich die treuesten Fans, die jemand hat.
Warum kickt
man so jemanden von der Bühne, ja?
Warum beleidigt man seine Fans auf Twitter
danach? Möchte man keine Fans
mehr haben? Frag ich mich da nur.
Ich weiß nicht,
also übelst beklagt. Ja, also,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin,
im Endeffekt eigentlich nur,
weil mich einer gefragt hat, wie es mit den Mädels läuft.
Da ist mir einfach mal eingefallen,
die einzige Schnittmenge, die ich
quasi mit dem deutschen Hip-Hop sehe.
Max in Konzert,
confirmed, ja. Übrigens, was ich
auch nicht verstehe ist,
ähm, muss gleich ins Blatt, ja,
ähm, was ich auch nicht verstehe ist,
dass viele,
dass viele schreiben so nach dem Motto,
dass sie den größten Schwanz haben und sowas.
Also, wisst ihr eigentlich,
um jetzt mal hier Fun-Fact
oder unnützen Fact noch mal
rauszuhören, wisst ihr eigentlich, warum
alle antiken Skulpturen, die ihr so
seht, ja, selbst von, keine Ahnung,
Herkules, der eigentlich den größten
überhaupt haben müsste, warum die alle so
kleine Dinger haben?
Wisst ihr, warum das so ist?
Das ist, weil die Griechen
und die Griechen, die waren schlau, das wissen wir ja,
die Griechen waren echt Big Brain.
Die Griechen
haben gesagt, so nach dem Motto,
wer unten viel hat, kann oben nicht viel haben.
Das war so,
das war so Redewendung im,
im antiken
Griechenland.
Deswegen haben die Skulpturen alle so kleine.
Ja, deswegen würde ich
mal hinterfragen,
ob die nicht vielleicht sogar recht hatten, wenn ich mir das
angucke, wer sich da auf Twitter
immer so streitet, wer den größten hat.
Vielleicht haben die den
größten, aber dafür halt an anderer Stelle
nicht so viel.
Max kleiner Schniedelkonform.
Wenn es dazu führt, dass ich Big Brain
habe, kann ich damit leben, ja.
Außerdem ist es kein Problem.
Ich kriege so viele
Enlargement-Spam-Mails,
wenn es darauf ankommt, dann
wird er, wird er enlarged
halt. Kein Ding.
Wir wissen ja, dass die ganzen Spam-Mails aus Nigeria
vollkommen
vertrauenswürdig sind.
Ja, Leute, wir haben so gut
wie nichts gemacht von dem, was im Videotitel steht.
Ich hoffe,
euch hat das Stream trotzdem gefallen.
Hoffe ich.
Wir gucken jetzt noch mal kurz.
Tanzverbot! Streamt!
IEL in Berlin.
Ja, ihr Süßen,
alles fit.
Aber sowas von.
Haben die Katze hier?
Doch, ich glaube schon.
Wen haben wir denn hier? Dancing Mom.
Okay, vergesst das, was ich vor
10 Minuten erzählt habe.
Gibt es
ordentlich, ordentlich Futter gibt es hier.
Ja, weg damit, gebäckert.
Alter.
Man kann es mit dem Ausschnitt
auch übertreiben.
Was, in Lothrix? Ah, hier, guck mal da.
Was machen wir jetzt bis zum
Modern Warfare? Den müssen wir nicht rausnehmen.
Der hat genug, der hat genug Fieber.
Lass mal lieber irgendwie...
Okay.
Weiter unten müssen wir nicht gucken. Da sind irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Bootcamp-Grills. Wir gucken mal,
was in Science and Technology
ist. Da haben wir wenigstens ein bisschen Big Brain-Content.
Weil ich weiß, mein Chat weiß
Big Brain-Content zu schätzen. Stimmt's?
Chat.
Sudoku-Programmieren.
Flutter und Dart.
Cute-Livestreams.
Na, das ist doch was. Cute-Livestream.
Der 3D-Printer ist wieder da.
Wo ist denn, wo ist denn der BWL-Stream?
Wo ist denn dieser komische BWL-Stream,
der hier immer letztens am Start war?
Den hat wohl keiner geguckt, würde ich sagen.
Was, der Sigismund ist live?
Schreibt man den, schreibt man den so?
Ach, da. Ja.
Ich sieg, ich sieg.
Oh ne, das Spiel
macht mir null.
Was macht der, was macht der, was macht der?
Das gibt's bei Twitter
Gott sei Dank alles nicht.
Hat recht. Twitter, bestes, bestes
soziales Social-Gedöns.
Ähm. Aber den müssen wir
nicht hosten, der hat 7,5k.
Ich würd' keinen lieber...
Guck mal von denen, denen ich folge, ob da
irgendwas dabei ist, was man hostet.
Wie können, wie können
Visual Studio hosten?
Wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Microsoft streamt ihre
Developer-Sachen mittlerweile,
mittlerweile, oh Gott, CosmosDB,
das ist Azure-Gedöns, ähm,
auf, auf Twitch.
Ihr wisst ja, was ich mich frage, warum sie streamen das auf Twitch
und nicht auf Mixer.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum die das nicht auf Mixer streamen, aber
ich will die mal nicht auf blöde Ideen bringen, weil
sonst streamen sie den Kack demnächst, also,
das ist guter Content, ne, sonst streamen sie
den Kram demnächst auf Mixer. Wir wollen die Leute
ja mal nicht auf falsche Ideen bringen.
Irgendwie finde ich, Leute, ich finde keinen
zum hosten. Ich hoffe, euch hat der
Stream gefallen, wir sehen uns, ähm,
weiter. Hab ich euch eigentlich schon das Beste
erzählt, Leute? Hab ich euch das Beste
noch gar nicht erzählt? Soll Tanzverbot
hosten. Wir haben alle schon genug
Viewer.
Ähm, das Beste ist,
auch für Videos auf YouTube,
morgen
hab ich nochmal Azure-Schulung,
hier, da gemme ich meine restlichen
98 Euro aus,
und danach, danach hab ich
Freitag frei,
Wochenende frei,
Montag frei,
und die ganze Woche drauf frei.
Heißt, da kann ich
huge Content
machen. Besser als nichts,
und vielleicht kennt er mich ja. Er hat
sogar letztens in dem Stream irgendwas, äh,
gesagt über mich, hat einer einen Link gepostet.
Ja, aber ich host lieber kleinere
Leute, aber ich find, nein.
Hat mich letztens gehostet, der hat sich
überlegt, ob ich
gehostet hab. Ähm,
so, ich guck mal, dass ich keine Subs
übersehen hab. Nope, hab ich nicht.
So, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Wir machen an der Stelle Schluss. Ich find keinen zum hosten.
Ob das auch was bringen würde,
der nicht schon mehrere tausend Zuschauer
hat. Ähm,
Beatport, dein Sub, der steht
gar nicht drin. Hast du heute
gesubt?
Echt?
Der steht nicht drinne?
Hogos.
Nice Subscriber.
Ach, hast du auch
geschenkt bekommen. Echt, heute?
Komisch, aber das hätte ich trotzdem
sehen müssen. Äh, ja,
Surf Jelly, guck's dir einfach an.
Auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt zu wissen.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
Liegesmund oder Tanzverbot?
Okay. Wer, wen soll
ich hosten? Wir raiden
ihn. Raid.
Siegesmund.
Okay.
Wursche Studio.
Elotrix. Ja, warte. Deswegen
hoste ich keinen, weil ich nicht weiß...
Okay, Siegesmund. Siegesmund.
Alles klar. Also,
hosten wir ihn.
Gut, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Blasenentzündung. Der Plörre hier kriegst du
alles andere auch mit dazu.
Pferd auf das Gras.